Boom,
and we're live.
Hello,
Kyle.
Hello.
Joe Rogan.
Do you look very good?
They're in a suit.
Thank you.
You know,
I like to pretend that I'm a serious
human being by wearing this,
but I'm just a dick.
Well,
you're a youngest fellow,
so maybe a suit would give you more of
an air of calm composure authority.
Perhaps.
That's the idea.
If you look like you're really serious
than people assume you're serious and
they don't know that I'm making Dick
Jokes and exactly like that.
It's a good movie.
It's very smart move.
I had some suits made.
I had to do this function for one of my
kids' schools and I had to go to this
function.
We had to wear nice clothes.
It's like a dress up thing and not
really have nice clothes,
nothing that like fits.
And so I had to have something made so
now I've been wearing it when I go on
special dates with Mrs Rogan.
So it's like,
it's a suit like this.
It's a nice suit,
jacket and tailored.
The whole deal fits me.
And how do you feel when you put it on?
Do you feel like a serious person?
I feel like a serious person,
like if I.
If I dress like this,
but like a hoodie and a tee shirt.
I feel like a Schlub.
I feel like a Dork.
Graham,
there's this thing that I do wear,
especially when I'm doing my show.
Oftentimes you do that half assed move
where I look like this,
but yeah,
but then the shorts on or I might have
sweat pants sometimes.
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
It all depends on what mood I'm in.
I mean sometimes I'll,
I'll do the whole thing and look nice,
but usually I'm just being lazy and one
Guy Ritchie who was on the podcast and
he made a very good statement in defense
of the suit.
It was a.
It was a really interesting sort of
testimony in defense of the suit and the
pocket square.
He's a big believer of the pocket
square,
which I think is preposterous.
That's a little too far.
It's too far.
I'm with you,
but it doesn't go out of style.
That's the thing is like if you look at
a picture of somebody from like
Nineteen,
Oh six,
and you look at a picture of somebody
from 2018 and they're wearing a suit,
you go,
oh,
okay.
But then other aspects of style and
fashion change so fast.
I mean you look at.
Remember the,
I think they were called Chanko is like
the really baggy jeans that people wore.
Oh yeah,
like a cabaret cheese.
I don't know what that is.
Is that,
that really was something that we used
to where I'm dating myself.
This is like in the early nineties,
late eighties,
early nineties.
It was like they were tight to like
your,
your pelvic region and then they would
flare up when they got past MC hammer
pants.
So terrible.
But those didn't really make it right.
And then there were,
but they did make it in the gym.
Like if you go to the gym,
there's still guys who were these kinds
of sweat pants that are like these kind
of Puffy sweatpants.
They're usually juiced out of their
minds.
Right?
These are the workout clothes.
Everybody wears it.
Probably wear those pants because there
it is.
There's cavalry cheese.
Oh my God.
I used to wear those.
Try to get laid.
That's the opposite of trying to get
laid.
Not In those days.
Back in those days like people didn't
know any better.
Right,
but it's
like eggs is that things change except
powdered wigs.
Exactly.
Like people.
People came from.
No.
We found out on the podcast.
He came from syphilis.
Yes.
The whole wig thing came out of royalty.
These royals had syphilis.
What was the whole story?
It was about the term big wig and it was
who were the people was a Dutch Dutch
kings who is the.
Who were the kings,
so you could find that story because
it's a fascinating story.
What it was was there was these,
I think they were brothers and they had
syphilis.
They were just banging everybody.
Yeah.
Why do people wear powdered wigs and it
all came from a hair loss that these
guys would have.
There it goes.
The proof story begins.
Like many others with syphilis by 15 a,
the std had become the worst epidemic to
strike Europe since the black death,
according to William Close.
Klaus,
close C,
l o w e s,
how would you say that either one.
Close.
I say an infinite multitude of syphilis.
Patients clogged London's hospitals and
more filtered in each day without
antibiotics.
Victims face the full brunt of the
disease,
open sores,
nasty rashes,
blind,
endless demand blindness,
dementia and patchy hair loss.
Baldness swept the land.
So that's what I'm saying.
I'm healthy.
Well,
they just,
it just became a thing because these raw
scroll down.
So it'll tell you like who the people
were that did it.
Yeah.
So,
um,
it went a little too far and so syphilis
outbreak sparked a surgeon which making
wig making victims hid their baldness,
blah,
blah.
Louis,
the 14th was only 17 when his mom
started thinning,
worried that his baldness would hurt his
reputation.
Louis hired 48 week makers to save as
image.
Five years later,
the King of England,
Louise,
cousin Charles,
the second did the same thing when his
hair started to gray.
Both men,
likelihood syphilis,
cordy airs.
How do you say that?
Courtney,
Courtney Hayes and other aristocrats
immediately copied the two kings.
They sported wigs and the style trickled
down to the upper middle class.
Europe's newest fad was born and so
that's where it came from.
So the whole powdered wigs with people
of distinction in court,
all that shit came from syphilis.
What's like most things?
Well,
whenever somebody tries to,
you know,
Kinda like deify the founding fathers,
I always think,
well yeah,
they were brilliant on some things,
but on the other hand they wore powdered
wigs and shat.
Now's outhouses and enslaves.
Yeah.
So like there's a little bit of a
balance that we have to take into
consideration.
Well,
I mean,
think about how much cultural change has
taken place in our society just over the
last few years.
Sure.
You mean words that were commonplace are
now completely unacceptable.
You know,
styles of behavior and methods of
expression are being criticized and
critiqued.
It this really radical way.
And I think it's good.
I ultimately,
I think there's a lot of bad.
I'd say it's good,
but the sentiment is good,
you know,
I think the,
and some of the overreaction,
like there's a spectrum,
right?
There's always going to be like,
did you see the,
there was something that came out
yesterday from Portland State University
where Peter but goes in and James Damore
the Google memo guy and uh,
heather hiding.
She was a professor at Evergreen state
and I remember what the Jordan Peterson
and she was actually on my podcast last
week with her husband,
Bret Weinstein.
Weinstein can't stay wind.
I'm not thinking of the same person.
I was thinking of the person who got
fired because of,
she'd not function and get fired,
but she criticized her for playing a
Jordan Peterson thing.
Is that the same person?
No,
no,
no.
That's Lindsey.
She was in a different university.
Okay.
A Canada in Canada,
another university in Canada.
Um,
this is in Portland.
Anyway,
so they're in the middle of this
conversation.
And Heather who is a,
she's a biologist and she starts going
over the biology of the differences
between males and females that are
undeniable and these kids get up and
they started yelling that this is
bullshit and fuck you and power to the
people,
all this crazy shit.
And then they tip over the sound system
and they're the most hilarious classical
liberal,
progressive lefties,
green hair.
The guy who was like this poofy Afro and
he's like,
you know,
we don't tolerate Nazis man,
like fucking Nazis or biologist.
He's a shit.
That stuff is the kind of stuff that I
think turns people off to the left and
almost provides a gateway to the right.
We're all of a sudden people can buy
into and even broader right wing
ideology because if you look at the left
and that's your perception of the left
is it's the people with the pink hair or
the blue hair and they're just going
around and their whole point is two d
platform.
People are sensor.
People are screaming about Ben Shapiro
or whatever the case is.
Like my whole thing is put.
If you're on the left.
And I think most lefties do this to be
fair.
Put the identity politics aside.
Okay.
And let's talk about the things that we
actually already have a majority of the
American people with us on.
So you know,
like a classic leftwing idea.
Let's have a living wage.
The minimum wage is not a living wage
right now.
You could work full time and not make
enough money to survive.
Well,
if you're on the left and you go out
there and you talk about we need to
fight to try to get a living wage and
make our government work for us.
Well then you get everybody to agree
with you.
Even most Republicans agree with you.
It didn't go down the list.
Whether it's legalizing marijuana is 60
percent of the American people are now
with us ending the wars.
There was a poll that came out in a
2013,
so it's old admittedly,
but only 17 percent of the American
people still want it to be in the,
in the war in Afghanistan.
And we're still there today.
I'd imagine if anything,
that number probably dropped even
further.
And everybody's like,
what are we doing in Afghanistan?
Right?
But isn't.
The problem with polls is when you ask
people about it,
you're not asking them if they're
informed.
You're just asking you.
You're just asking your opinion on it.
What I was saying about the left versus
the right is that the real problem is
anybody can be on either,
so you're going to get these people that
are going to disrupt this heather hiring
lecture on biology from an informed
scientific perspective and like,
fuck,
this man is a patriarchy.
You're going to get that,
but you're also going to get people like
yourself.
You're also gonna.
Get people that are aware of the issues
and educated and are debating this in a
very public way and trying to figure out
what's the best possible solution to
these things.
The problem is anytime you have a group,
whether it's pick the group gun owners,
vegans,
what are anybody can fucking join man,
and as soon as anybody can join,
you can't look at like the worst case
scenarios.
The green haired Dork that kicks over
the microphone because they don't like
the idea that heather is speaking
logically about biology.
Like no,
you have to look at like the the whole
thing.
Sure.
And we don't like to do that.
We'd like to point at the green hair
dork and say,
hey liberals,
there's your left Sharon.
Exactly.
And you know the breakdown to me is when
you look at somebody like that,
they're in the category of what I would
call authoritarian left because they
want to control other people's actions.
They want to shut down that speech and
say,
your ideas are so dangerous.
I don't even want to hear it.
There's a whole nother contingent of the
left,
which again I would argue is probably
the majority of the left,
which is the libertarian left,
which is people like me and many others
who say,
listen,
live and let live on social issues.
I'm never,
even though I don't agree with Steve,
Steven crowder bench purell on anything,
I'm never gonna,
you know,
try to protest.
To get them to not speak their mind at a
school is foolish.
It makes it look like you don't have an
argument when you say,
I can't let that guy talk,
and then they get to go around and say,
I'm so persecuted because I'm right.
Right,
right.
You know.
Meanwhile I say,
okay,
you want to have somebody like that go
speak to college.
Sure,
fine.
Let them speak.
Let me get this speech after.
Well,
it's good enough.
I mean,
I think open conversations are critical
and I also.
This is going to probably be unpopular.
I don't think the way to do it is in
front of a large group of people.
I think you open yourself up to a lot of
grandstanding,
a lot of saying things just for applause
breaks a lot of.
There's a lot of bullshit.
It just.
It changes the nature of the
conversation because it becomes theater.
You're doing this thing in front of all
these people and you can hear a lot of
these times people say things like,
I'm a comic,
so I know when someone's saying things
for reaction,
there's a way you do it.
Will you say it like this and that's
what we want.
And everybody goes,
you do not,
you do not talk like that when it's just
you and a person was just you and a
person.
You are just alone with your ideas.
And I think that is the way a guy like
Ben Shapiro and,
you know,
put whoever you want on the left should
have a discussion.
Yeah.
Um,
there's something about that,
that soft history,
you know,
like,
so you're not creating the best
argument.
You're just trying to sound like you
have the best argument.
And you know,
Bill Maher,
for example,
does this where he's very at the punchy
one liners.
Sure.
Like he's in a conversation with his
panel on his show and it'll be like
blah,
blah.
And there was
a comment,
say anything you just kept,
it was like a quick partisan hacky point
you made.
But since people already agree with you
in the audience,
they clap.
So it's hard to flesh out the ideas.
And really that's why.
Listen,
I've always said I'm not the biggest fan
of debate because.
So I've done a few debates and people
online like when I do debates,
but I'm not the biggest fan of debates
because I think it's like the wwe of
intellectual pursuits where you go in,
this person's whole point is to defend
this side of it.
My job is to defend the other side of it
and it's like,
okay,
clash.
But it's like,
okay,
well then when we come across an issue
like the fucking 64 genders on facebook
or whatever it is,
and I actually might agree,
am I now put in a position where I'm
supposed to be like,
no,
I'm going to disagree because that's the
format of the thing that we're doing.
It's just weird and it's not normal.
Yeah,
and I think that's actually very
important for both sides to do.
Like when there's something on your side
of the disagree with you should be
honest about it.
And even saying that that there's a side
that there are sides,
that there's our side versus their side.
We're.
I think we're so inherently tribal that
we should resist any temptation
whatsoever to form teams,
especially about critical issues.
Like really important social issues,
really important economic issues,
really important civil rights issues.
These are just things that we should
just talk about without looking at them
in terms of,
oh,
the left wants this,
so I oppose it or the right ones this.
So I have to figure out ways to mock it.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I don't even know what to say in
response to that.
I agree with that.
You know,
it was,
we were talking about this before the
podcast that like what I try to do is
have conversations with everyone.
I tried to have conversations with nutty
people like Alex Jones.
I try to have conversations with
rational people like Sam Harris.
I touch on have conversations with all
kinds of people,
but without fail,
every time I have a left wing person on
um,
some Kuk left wing.
Yeah.
You know,
what's going to happen anytime I have a
right wing person on,
um,
some.
All right.
Nazi apologist.
It's like this weird inclination we have
to try to label and categorize people
and I try to resist those labels as much
as humanly possible.
Well,
I feel like what you're really good at
is you can have on people who disagree
completely on stuff,
but you'll kind of find a nugget of
agreement in the conversation with that
person and then you can expand on that
and you can end up having a very nice
conversation and you're not.
You never really bring anybody on to try
to like brow beat them and tell them
that they're wrong on this issue or that
issue.
You know what I mean?
I have no desire to do that.
I don't know.
I mean,
look,
I've had.
I've had a lot of arguments in my life
and I don't like them.
I don't think they're beneficial.
I mean,
I think debate is good,
but every time I've ever been in an
argument with someone,
like a real argument always come out of
it.
Feeling Gross.
Yeah.
You're.
There are times in life or arguments are
necessary.
There's times in life where you're just
faced with aggression or conflict and
you have to do something about it.
You have to meet it head on.
There are times in likely that,
but whenever you can avoid that do and I
think a lot of what arguments are,
and I failed at this in my life many
times,
but a lot of what arguments are is the
way you've reacted to the the thoughts
and the expression that another person
has and if you just reacted a different
way or approach it in a different manner
or took it into consideration a little
bit more before you responded.
I think the conversation could have gone
another way and I think I'm learning how
to do that more and more as I get better
at podcasting,
at better at conversations,
learning how to just settle someone down
and learning how to genuinely be a nice
person.
So I don't.
I don't want to insult anybody.
I don't want to be in a disagreement
with someone.
I want to discuss ideas.
Sure.
Who was that?
Who is that skeptic guy from years back
that he put you on the list of top 10
conspiracy,
blah blah,
and then running,
and then I remember watching that clip
and it was so frustrating when you guys
were going back and forth because you
would say,
I think you were talking about the 9:11
thing and you're like,
I'm 100 percent.
Not saying it was a conspiracy.
I'm saying it looked like the building
came down in a controlled demolition.
Those are two very different things.
It's one thing to say,
I believe it's a conspiracy.
It's another thing to say the way it
came down a look like it was a
controlled demolition,
but he kept insisting and trying to tell
you what you believe as you're sitting
across the room and you're like,
no,
I don't believe that.
He was trying to tell me what I was
saying.
Right.
And it was
clear in all,
okay,
how do I say this?
Uh,
I don't think Brian is a bad guy.
I don't think his brain works correctly.
I'm being honest.
I think there's,
there's a real problem there.
And when he does these science,
these videos,
he sounds like a strip club Dj.
Do you know what I mean?
Like I've never seen his original
content that people talk.
Will they take on an effective.
There's a wet heat,
but that thing is done by people that
are trying to achieve a desired result.
Like it's not that they're themselves
talking about a very specific thing,
it's that they are trying to put on an
air of intellectual authority and you
know,
he talks to himself as a science writer,
whatever that is.
Like,
I don't hate that guy.
I'm not mad at him.
The whole thing was kind of foolish and
it was very damaging to him.
And he wound up going to jail
afterwards.
Really?
Yeah.
Not because of that,
but because of something that he did,
he was involved some sort of scam with,
uh,
was it Amazon or Google?
Ebay.
That's right.
He was involved in some sort of a scam
or he had an embedded cookies.
You'd go to his site and make it.
Made it look like when you were buying
things online that you had gone through
his site first.
When in fact you hadn't,
there was just a cookie that was
embedded,
some,
something along those lines.
Whatever it was,
it was illegal and they wind up going to
jail.
So,
and even his defense of that,
it's like,
I think there's something wrong there.
I
don't know what that something is,
where there's a,
there's a spark plug that's not screwed
in all the way.
There's something wrong.
Well,
speaking of a fake personas,
I feel like that's the worst when it
comes to politics and I do feel like
there's very,
very,
very few upsides of trump in my opinion.
But one of the upsides of trump is that
he did kind of break the mold in terms
of what was viewed as,
um,
the right way to communicate as a
politician.
Because before him you had all these
very measured people who had the proper
posture and they spoke with their thumb
pointing down because they don't want to
be strong with their finger pointing at
you like that fist.
And then he comes along and he's
obviously shooting from the hip and he
clearly has no filter and he's tripping
over his words a tremendous,
believe me,
he's unnecessarily punchy and short with
his sentences.
And I remember there was a report that
came out that said he communicates,
I think it was like a sixth or seventh
grade level or something like that and
everybody in the media was mocking it.
And I did a segment where I said you
guys are mocking and that's a terrible
idea because guess what?
The way he speaking,
even though it sounds stupid,
it's going to pierce through like,
you know how when some people talk it's
hard.
You have to focus to pay attention to
listen to where they're going with it
and it's hard.
And then there's other people who talk
and it's like you just,
you just get it.
It's immediately right in your brain and
he doesn't matter.
Agree or disagree with the substance of
what that person is saying.
You know,
when somebody is an effective
communicator.
And when he was at out there on the
campaign trail and he was,
for example,
campaigning in the rust belt where
Hillary Clinton did not go right.
And he was like,
ah,
Nafta enough,
just terrible.
They shipped out all your jobs.
It was unbelievably terrible.
Believe me,
let me just tell you what I'm going to
do.
I'm going to keep your jobs here.
It's going to be unbelievable.
Believe me.
That's pretty good.
I'd say it is good,
right?
I do.
Pretty good trump people tell me a
little off,
but the matter is,
these are excellent.
So the fucking thing he did recently
where he said that he had gone into the
school when the school shooting was
going on in their unit who didn't have a
gun.
Yeah.
It's like we mentioned any other setting
that you can't.
I was with him when he was like
listening to cops should have gone in
and everybody's like,
yeah,
of course the cops had gotten.
Yeah.
But then he has to gratuitously take it
so much further.
Then he goes,
I would have gone in and then he adds
without a weapon.
Like now everybody knows you're just
full of shit and manage.
If he was there,
oh,
imagine if he was there,
like if trump just happened to be there
giving a speech at the school in a
school shooting started and uh,
and he didn't do anything.
He just stood on the outside.
We know he would have a guarantee.
I mean,
he's the guy who said,
oh,
my personal Vietnam was avoiding stds at
the [inaudible] I went to.
Pretty funny.
Yeah.
So that was,
isn't,
it wasn't a scene in,
um,
the dead zone.
Yeah.
I didn't see the dead zone wells in the
book.
In fact,
the guy uses someone to shield him from
a shooter and that's what keeps that guy
from ever becoming president.
So it keeps him from pressing the button
because the guy was going to become
president and he was going to launch a
nuclear war,
uh,
assault and nuclear war.
And this guy that,
uh,
was Christopher walken's.
Kay was Christopher Walken was right
thing.
So he realized by touching this guy's
hand,
this guy was going to do this.
And so there was some scenario took
place where someone was trying to shoot
him and he used someone else to shield
him from the bullet and that's what
prevented him from ever becoming
president.
And what's the,
it's a movie that dead zone.
It's a movie and it's also a,
it was also a book by Stephen King.
I'm trying to read the book and I saw
the movie.
I'm trying to remember.
Was it walking?
Yeah.
Fuck,
that's right.
That's right.
Young walking.
Look at that handsome face bastard.
It was a weird looking dude.
Where does,
where does it gets?
But that's what's cool about them.
It's great movie though.
Fun Mate might not be great anymore.
It might be one of those movies.
Like I always told people we should
watch altered states.
It's amazing.
And then I watched it.
Certain things age so bad.
We were just talking about it.
Um,
I don't know,
but especially with comedy and you've
pointed this out,
if you go back and look at old comedy,
it's just a different world.
They were living,
standup and exactly you.
If you take the conversation we're
having and you like somehow get it back
to 1950,
people will look at us like just the
fact that we casually curse and you
know,
the concepts we're talking about,
they'd be like,
this is unbelievably impolite.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Well,
one of the best examples I think is
Stephen Colbert saying that president
trump uses his mouth is Putin's cock
holster.
Just set it on whatever network,
tv or cable,
whatever the Johnny Carson do with that.
I mean,
no way.
Go back to the old Ed Sullivan show.
You know where Jackie Mason got banned
for life because it looked like he gave
the finger.
He did this thing right?
Like this.
This is what I do.
I'm Jackie Mason.
He says he never even gave him the
finger,
but he was accused of giving someone the
finger and that was it.
He was banned.
Didn't they do that with Elvis when he
performed?
He like moved his hips in a way that
they thought was too sexual.
So they're like,
we can't show this because there are
kids that exist in the world.
Well,
they would only frame him from the waist
up.
They wouldn't show all that thought
motion.
It was too much.
Fuck on what Elvis.
Come on man.
That's so goofy.
Like I don't get what it is about
different times.
I mean there were just a few generations
away from the powdered wigs.
I mean really that's,
I mean that's such a different world.
I can't wrap my mind around it,
but you know what?
It's true that I.
Who Was it?
I think it was lenny bruce who had all
these different lawsuits against him
because so in a way he's like,
he kind of paved the way for people like
us where you,
especially because you're in comedy too,
but even just for the Internet where we
have this,
you know,
this free open platform where we talk
about whatever.
I feel like we wouldn't even be able to
get away with talking,
you know,
mentioning the sexual stuff or cursing
if it wasn't for guys like that who
paved the way because people were
getting arrested for doing a standup set
and cursing 100 percent.
I have a bunch of framed lenny bruce
posters in my house.
Yeah.
I think he,
uh,
is one of the most important figures in
the history of pop culture because he,
he was a way ahead of his time,
you know,
just way,
way ahead of his time.
He had jokes back then that I saw people
stealing in the 19 eighties.
Wow.
I don't even know if they were stealing
it.
I rephrase that.
I think they might've had parallel
thinking.
One of the jokes was about gay people
that in certain places being gay and
like sodomy is actually,
I think sodomy is still technically
illegal in some places.
In some states I think.
Yeah.
Hippy or some shit,
which includes going down on somebody.
By the way.
No blow jobs are technically illegal in
some states.
That's fucking hilarious.
Right.
But um,
what was my point that.
Oh,
so his joke was that he was dig this
man,
if you're gay,
he goes,
uh,
they put you in jail with a bunch of men
who have sex with you.
I mean,
that's a joke that can last.
That's a fucking joke.
That would work today.
If nobody figured that out today and it
didn't exist in,
somebody just said that on stage today.
You know,
there's a lot of those though that
people like they don't realize it's been
said before because it just seems like
that happens.
Of course.
Even in what I do,
political commentary,
I'll make points and it'll be a point
that eight people made before me.
I think I'm some fucking genius over
here.
It's unavoidable.
Especially with like obvious points.
Like when I started out in Boston doing
stand up,
we're obviously right next to New
Hampshire and New Hampshire's state
motto on their license plate is live
free or die.
And I said,
yeah,
those plates are made by prisoners.
How fucked up is that?
And I'm sure it is.
I am absolutely positive.
Other people thought that up as well
because that's always been a thing,
right?
Like people would make fun of.
Prisoners would make license plates.
Like it was like a see in movies.
Like yeah,
you're going to go make license plates.
Like that's what happened.
You know,
they put the cuffs on him,
you know?
Yeah.
Now you'll be making license plates like
for some reason like being in prison was
associated with making license plates
there and there's some,
just because you brought up prisons,
there's a pivot here,
but there's some creepy stuff going on
in terms of the Labor that they're
getting from prisoners.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
We were just talking about that with the
fires that they were paying.
Those guys got a dollar a day to risk
their life in the Santa Barbara fires.
Fuck man.
How was that allowed hate maybe give me
a month off,
you know,
or a year off or whatever.
You know,
maybe if you did,
you're not a dangerous criminal,
like maybe did something stupid,
you know,
some petty theft or something like that
and you know,
look,
I'll go out there and fuck the fire,
but you gotta you gotta give me some
sort of a break off my sentence.
Nope.
We're going to give you a dollar a day.
So they make them do it and then they
still had the normal sentence.
They don't even reduce it or anything.
I don't know.
I wish I did.
I mean,
I'm sure good behavior,
reducing sentences,
I'm sure that probably does something,
but the idea that they could pay you a
dollar a day to fight a fire.
It's fucking crazy or a dollar an hour
or whatever the fuck the actual number
was.
The way we do prisons in general
in the US is really weird because I feel
like there's like the Norwegian way of
doing stuff and the Scandinavian way of
doing stuff where they gear everything
towards rehabilitation to get them back
into society and functioning.
Um,
and in the US I feel like we don't gear
it towards rehabilitation.
We gear it towards punishment.
We're going to punish you and you know,
I,
I think you could,
there are fair critiques of the
Norwegian system like in Scandinavia.
What,
who's The guy?
Andrews Brevig,
he killed all these.
Anyone that was complaining because he's
like,
I only have a ps two and you guys need
to give me like a newer video game
system so you can look at that and go,
listen man,
you guys are being too fucking liberal.
Fuck that guy.
He had like two rooms that were his cell
and he could walk into fucking court
yard and shit.
So I think there are genuine criticisms
of that,
but at the same time what's fascinating
is they have a significantly lower
recidivism rate than we do.
So here,
if you go to prison,
it's very likely that you're going to
end up back in prison in those places.
If you go to prison,
you know,
especially if it's like a lower level
crime,
they rehabilitate you and you get out
and you're a functioning member of
society so we can learn something from
them.
In my mind,
I think there should be some sort of a
middle ground like I think prison should
be used.
Yes.
In some instances people need fucking
punishment in some instances of course,
but we need to mix that in many
instances with a healthy dose of
rehabilitation as well.
So we are our,
I don't know,
functioning like an actual society as
opposed to jailing more people in this
country than any other country in the
world.
I don't necessarily think that
punishment by itself helps anybody.
I mean,
if you take a gun and you lock them in a
cell and he's in that little tiny cell
until his body stops working and he
dies,
is that helping anybody?
I mean,
who is that helping?
So are there some city?
So for me,
I feel like there are some situations
where I get the idea of like life in
prison without the possibility for.
Yeah,
I get it too.
But I mean why look at a Ted Bundy
character or some something along those
lines.
Just indefensible,
right?
Some serial killer,
a psychopath.
What do you do?
Fucking kill him.
Just going to ask you,
how do you feel about the death penalty,
but now I know.
Kill him.
Just come on Mandy.
There's not enough time in the world to
fix a Ed gain your or who was the
fucking clown?
William Casey.
The clown guy who killed all those kids
and burden in his backyard.
Yeah.
There's some people that Cleveland
somewhere in Ohio.
So your,
your,
your place buddy.
There are some people who are just.
The point you're making is there are
some people who are too far gone.
When I say you're a place,
I'm not talking to you,
I'm talking to Jamie for people just
listening,
like why is he fucking with Kyle and
saying he's involved with the cloud.
It's just to know I might not have even
been Ohio,
might've been pittsburgh somewhere dark
and cloudy.
So the point you're making is that there
are people who are too far gone and,
and I agree with that a hundred percent.
So.
But my whole thing on the death penalty
is I've always thought the idea of it in
principle is something I get.
Like you could point out all those
people who did those horrific things and
like there's no hope of them
rehabilitating their total monsters.
And I say philosophically,
I have no problem getting rid of those
people because you're just eliminating a
problem.
But in my mind,
the reason why I'm not in favor of the
death penalty is because four percent of
the time we get the wrong people.
Right?
So if you have a system where you're
guaranteed to kill the wrong people some
percentage of the time,
then what we're saying is,
well,
we're going to let the state murder
people for percent of the time and
that's something that I just can't have
my tax dollars going towards.
You know what I mean with you 100
percent,
but is it any better to have those
people locked up in a cage for the rest
of their life until their body stops
working?
Well,
I guess the idea is if you have them
locked up and you have people at the
innocence project working on trying to
overturn cases where there was a wrong
conviction that eventually you can write
the wrong of getting those wrong people
four percent of the time,
but it's finite.
If you say no,
you're going to,
we're going to put you on on death row
and you're going to die in eight years,
or whatever it is.
Then sometimes you can't finish the case
in time to overturn it.
And so that's my whole thing about the
dead.
Like I,
I agree philosophically,
and that's something many people to my
left have come after me for and said,
no,
you're wrong.
You should be against the death penalty
in principle,
but I say,
no,
I get it theoretically and
philosophically,
but it's just that when you actually
implement it,
there are pragmatic problems like,
you're going to kill the wrong fucking
people and I'm not okay with that.
You know what I mean?
I don't know if it's better to kill the
wrong people or to keep the wrong people
locked in a cage suffering for the rest
of their life.
Who were,
where did a William Casey live?
John Wayne gacy was on Wayne,
Chicago,
Chicago.
His middle name was Wayne.
John Wayne,
John Wayne gacy.
I didn't know that was William Gacy.
I'm thinking William Mason,
the guy from shameless.
I'm all fucked up.
Yeah.
Well,
we were talking about something before
the podcast and I think,
um,
uh,
this is,
I think this is really the future,
whether it's in our lifetimes or our
children's lifetimes,
but I think that they're going to be
able to read minds and I think it's not,
we're not far away from that.
We're going to really be able to know
the actual contents of your thoughts,
whether or not you really did murder a
bunch of kids,
burry them in your backyard.
We're going to know.
And until then we're dealing with a
bunch of really big fucking problems.
One of the biggest problems is people's
memories.
People's memories are so bad.
They're so bad.
So when you have eyewitness testimony
and you can convict people wrongly,
which happens every day,
and they think they're right,
they think they,
they really do believe they're right.
Really?
Believe it.
That's a fucking problem,
man.
That's just a giant problem is the human
memory is incredibly flawed.
And when someone's life is on the line
and you know you're going to convict,
the guy who didn't do anything,
he just looks kind of like what you
remember this person who murdered that
guy looks like,
well,
that's where a lot of the things get
overturned is because they had dna
evidence that overrides whatever the
testimony was that the people at the
time and speaking of technology
advancing it,
there's many scary aspects to it.
But,
you know,
the elephant in the room to me is the
fact that look at what the NSA is
already doing.
They're already spying on absolutely
everybody in the country.
They collect all of our metadata and
stored.
It's a multibillion dollar facility in
Utah.
And then like,
there's no doubt that all this
technology is going to be used against
us.
You know what I mean?
Well,
it certainly can be if they choose to.
Like if you become a guy like a,
uh,
you know,
like Julian songs or who leaks something
and then they go,
hey,
let's go pull up Kyle's a text message
records.
Oh look,
he looks crossdressing fucking people's
mouths.
What?
Whatever it is.
I mean,
they,
they can and then they could leak that
to whatever media people that they're in
bed width.
There's just a lot of shit that they can
get away with.
Well,
that's partially what they did with
Eliot Spitzer because Elliot Spitzer,
they called them the sheriff of Wall
Street because crack down on Wall Street
and then,
oops,
look at that.
His,
his credit card information from the
brothel he went to was leaked to a press
outlet.
Well,
how the fuck did you get the credit card
information?
Because they knew what they were looking
for because they were trying to bring
him down that he was actually going
after brothel.
That's what I was going to say and I
think it was his hypocrisy that brought
him down and not the fact that he went
to a brothel stay.
You're cracking down on brothels and
going into brothels at the same.
Just arresting people.
Yeah.
Was fucked up.
It was ridiculous.
It's like if like.
I mean,
it doesn't make any sense that he
thought that he could get away with
that,
but the real problem with that guys,
that guy was an interesting politician.
He really did have some really good
points,
a lot like a wiener was kind of
interesting in that way too.
He had some really good points.
He's a great speaker,
but he was also free.
Did you see the documentary on him?
I did it.
I mean,
will you want to.
I didn't finish it though.
I've watched part of it and then I just
got bored.
I mean you want to talk about a fall
from grace.
He was somebody who was viewed as like,
oh,
there's fire breather on the left who
goes after people and doesn't take any
shit,
and then fast forward and it's like,
oh,
you got caught,
you know,
sending Dick Pics to like 80,000 women.
Some of them under age and I feel so bad
for his wife sending Dick Pics while he
was holding his kid,
his kid sending pictures of him with his
kid and his arms and his boner.
That's one of those scandals where it's
like,
nope,
you're not coming back for that.
Everybody's like,
fuck off.
This is what I said.
So I said on the podcast,
and I'm saying right now,
I think he's in jail right now.
Right?
Is he in jail?
He's in jail.
I don't know if you go into jail,
Andrew,
you're a comic.
You just don't know it.
I guarantee he's a comic.
He just never did it and he just went
into politics and you know,
he's a real good speaker.
He's kind of a funny guy.
Okay.
So I wanted to talk to you about comedy.
I really did because.
So I've had,
um,
I've done a few live things in my life.
I did a live show once and then,
um,
but I also did a best man speeches in
front of rooms of,
you know,
over 100 people.
The first one best man's speech I did,
I cried like a pitch.
It was the saddest thing ever.
I'm up there talking about one of my
best friends and I'm like,
we used to wrestle on the triple e.
It was,
it was pathetic.
It was pathetic though.
That's just some emotions you,
you care about the guy.
Well,
yeah,
that's the thing is that people came up
to me after and they,
they liked it and they were like,
Oh man,
that was great.
It was heartfelt.
I was like,
I barely fucking said a word that
anybody can understand cause I was
blubbering.
It was,
but that's okay.
But I think there's a real problem that
people have with avoiding emotions,
you know?
I was too vulnerable in front of people.
I didn't know that was a good banner.
You're defending me.
Thank you for that.
But the second best man speech I gave,
I went into it thinking like,
okay,
I'm gonna I'm gonna crush a little bit.
I was thinking that a little bit,
but like,
so I,
I like to,
when I talk I like to have just bullet
points of what I want to talk about and
just,
just a loose outline and then I'll riff
off of it.
And what happened was all the lines that
I thought would get a laugh did not get
a laugh,
but all my throwaway lines got good
laughs.
So I was amazed by that.
And then also I was amazed at the
fucking rush of getting a room to hang
on your every word and to genuinely
laugh at what you're saying.
Yeah.
And so every time you do stand up,
is that the feeling you get?
You definitely get a rush.
There's no doubt about it.
You crush,
you get a rush.
Yeah.
You get a.
well,
it's a different rush and different size
places like there's more of a surreal
thing when you get a.
there's a,
there's an area you get to like around
5,000,
6,000 people where it gets real.
It gets real weird,
man.
It gets fucking weird.
That gets weird.
Like almost like you are you just a,
you're doing a show then more than
you're connecting with people.
You're going to come to the comedy store
tonight.
That's a intimate place.
That's 150 people.
That's tight little small room and
that's like you're there,
you're there with the people.
It's different.
That's a rush too though.
That's a different.
It's a different rush.
They're all.
It's all a rush,
but
your responsibility to the material and
the delivery sort of overrides the rush
because you can't really get caught up
in and go,
wow,
this is amazing because you have to be
thinking about the timing.
You have to be tuned into exactly what
you're thinking about.
You can't be thinking about,
oh,
this is getting a lot of great laughs.
You have to honestly be thinking about
the actual subject.
People fucking know what you're thinking
about.
Man.
It's weird,
isn't it?
Well,
I think it's a type of hypnosis.
I think,
and I don't mean hypnosis like you,
you tricked the people into doing
something,
but I mean like you mind meld with the
audience and some sort of a weird way.
People know when you're on some sort of
a script and they know when you're
talking from the heart and it's really
strange because you could have somebody
who's well versed in going through a
script,
but there's still something that's
missing from what they're saying and I
feel like that's one of the many reasons
why this podcast is very popular because
you get people on here and you just have
a conversation and your you are really
connecting and then you're also really
connecting with people who are watching
because you're just having a
conversation.
It's like you're at a bar and
everybody's just kind of talking and
it's not like people come here and
they're like,
let me now go to my point that I was
going to make on this and this.
Because that's when people start to
yawn.
And that's actually why I think a lot of
the.
The older shows like you know the.
Not to shit on the late night hosts,
but that's why I feel like that kind of
dying out.
And there's this giant rise of the
Internet.
Because that's all very segmented and
structured and you have to go in and out
real fast and it's,
there's nothing human about it.
It's almost like it's celebrities
telling you were on this different level
and you're going to watch us be on this
different level as opposed to just being
a regular person and they like work with
Spielberg.
Well,
it's interesting.
Steven is a amazing director.
It's just,
it's just so huge.
And also you would be like the talk show
host,
so you'd be sitting there and I'd be
sitting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Which is weird.
And I'd be turning sideways facing him.
I mean it's so it's so follow leader
copycat because this is just the way
they did it with Jack Paar right back in
the fucking 18 hundreds,
whatever the fuck that was.
Right.
And they go from there to Jimmy Kimmel
who does it the same way and then the
first time somebody breaks the fuck and
mold.
Everybody's like,
what is this?
This is brilliant.
Why?
Why aren't we doing more of this?
This makes sense.
I mean,
you could kind of do this conversation
in front of a large group of people.
I mean,
a lot of people do do live podcasts.
I feel like it's a little different
though.
We're in the field,
so like that too because I don't know.
I feel like there's an energy that you
get from the audience where you kind of
try more to do those punchy one liners
on postage is flowing 100 percent.
Yeah,
you do.
And sometimes it's great.
Like I've done some live ones before
with friends and it's great and we did
the end of the world podcast.
We did a live podcast from the comedy
store at the night of the election and
during the election we realized that
trump,
we saying it's the end of the world no
matter who wins because you're writing,
but when trump won,
I mean bill burr was just on fire in
front of this fucking that guy.
Smart man,
smart.
Not just smart,
but that he had material about this that
was just perfect and it just was
crushing and there was a panel of six
other comics were all just laughing and
talking.
Shit though is a lot of fun.
And it worked.
That work.
That's one of the rare times that work,
but the way we did it was we had a chair
or a table set up and then we all sat
facing the audience and just talked,
you know,
like,
like a regular podcast but in front of a
live crowd.
And then someone would come out with
Brian Hennigan would come out and give
us the updates.
Trump is ahead by,
you know,
18 points.
So did,
did you see that coming trump winning or
no?
Um,
I thought it was entirely possible.
I didn't see it coming.
I felt like everybody was so convinced
that Hillary was gonna win.
I just felt like that was probably what
was going to happen.
So I feel like one of the reasons why
my,
my show got popular over is stuck in my
own digging.
This sounds so gross,
but,
but I actually predicted a pretty early
on when Hillary,
it was clear Hillary was going to get
the nomination.
I was sounding the alarms and I was
saying,
listen,
Hillary versus trump is a worst case
scenario because Hillary Clinton is the
status quo.
She is the establishment.
She is business as usual.
She doesn't have a message,
she doesn't have a vision.
All she's doing is spewing platitudes
and cliches,
break down the barrier,
stronger together,
doing identity politics nonstop,
which is nothing but pandering and not
talking about policy substance.
And then like we touched on earlier,
you had Donald Trump who,
uh,
I disagree with him on virtually
everything,
but the guy knows how to fucking play to
a crowd,
knows how to tell people what they want
to hear.
So when he's in front of a blue collar
audience,
he's out there ripping the trade deals
and say,
I'm going to keep your jobs in the
country and it's gonna be amazing.
And that's something that landed.
And then when you have hillary,
so dumb is to not a campaign.
And what Michigan and some Ohio was
whole house I think she went to,
but some of the rust belt states.
Well,
the reason he ended up winning is
because of the rust belt.
So and my whole point was trump is a
populist and admittedly when push came
to shove,
now that he's elected a fake populous
because he has Goldman Sachs throughout
his administration and you serving Wall
Street,
but a fake populist will always beat a
status quo politician.
Biggest people are sick and tired of
business as usual and they feel like,
well,
I'm getting shafted now and she's coming
along telling me I'm going to keep
everything the same.
Why the fuck would I be happy and
excited to vote for her?
It was like there was so many things
that were in place that were against
her.
First of all,
she would.
She has absolutely poor health and it
was admitted by her husband that she had
fallen down and cracked her head open
and had pretty severe brain injury that
she took.
Took more than six months for her to
recover.
According to bill,
we saw our fainting all the time.
I mean,
she,
yeah,
that was creepy at the nine slash 11
thing when she's not good.
It's just in the.
Oh,
she had the flu.
I've had the flu.
I don't fall asleep.
I'm standing up.
I mean,
that shit ain't good.
That's not good.
And that was just one thing.
The other thing is she's just a
disingenuous person when the whole comey
thing with the FBI,
when he,
when there was a video that came out
where he explained what the charges were
and what they had found about the emails
and then she explained the version of
it.
She's just not honest.
Yeah.
Then it was the whole gay marriage
thing.
She didn't support gay marriage.
Twenty 13,
13.
That's fucking crazy.
That's crazy.
And then here's the other thing,
she's a woman.
There's a lot of sexists.
There's a lot of people that didn't want
a woman to be president,
period.
Especially not a woman that could point
to all these floors.
Poor health,
liar,
dishonest in bed with Wall Street,
uh,
gets paid by banks.
Hundreds of thousand dollars won't
release the transcripts.
Clinton Foundation seems Kinda Shady.
There's so different things that were
against her.
She put the fact that she's a woman
front and center on with her was her
campaign slogan and you know what
happens when you try to shove identity
politics down people's throats.
They you to fuck off because they go,
I don't care that you're a woman.
I want to know what you're going to do
for the country,
but the people were that were into that.
We're telling her that that was going to
be her key to victory.
We're going to make history.
Nobody knows less about politics than
democratic strategist in Washington dc
because as of right now,
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to fight back against their base,
so they're based.
It's people like me and what we want.
I'm very clear about what I want.
It's not hard to please people like me
who are on the left.
We want a living wage.
We want Medicare for all which you know,
every other modern nation has one
version or another of a single payer
healthcare system.
We just want to be like the rest of the
modern world.
We want free college again,
Slovenia has fucking free college.
We can't afford to do free college when
we just spent seven fucking trillion
dollars on the Iraq war.
We want to end the wars.
So I have very clear policy goals that I
want.
And guess what?
Bernie Sanders came along,
spoke about those issues.
He went from being this obscure senator
from Vermont,
which has a population of 12 people to
getting 47 percent of the vote in a race
against a political juggernaut,
a behemoth that had the entire
Democratic Party machine behind her.
So they were rigging the primers 100
percent.
Yes.
And that's what we learned.
And that's why,
uh,
Julian assange went from being viewed
as,
oh my God,
this guy is great.
That's how the left used to view them.
And now many people,
democratic partisans are like,
ah,
fuck this Guy Russia,
Russia,
that I.
that's.
And I was just talking to you about this
before the podcast.
I was watching CNN before he came here
for about an hour and 30 minutes
nonstop.
Russia coverage,
nonstop,
fucking Russia coverage.
And then guess what?
Now when Donald trump goes out there and
he's a fake news,
CNN,
everyone's going to go,
yeah,
you know what?
All they do is fucking talk about Russia
all day long,
so maybe the guy has a point,
so the institutions that we have and the
establishment as it is,
it opens up the door for a demagogue and
a liar and a fake populist like trump to
come in there and exploited.
So if you give people a choice between a
broken system that's fucking them over
where half of workers in America make
$30,000 a year or less.
You give people an option between keep
everything as is or take a fucking human
bowling ball and throw it at the
establishment.
They're going to say,
okay,
fuck it.
We'll roll the dice on this trump guy.
And then meanwhile I look at his agenda
and everything that he's done since he's
got elected,
it's the opposite of his populist
rhetoric on the campaign trail.
His fucking tax bill had a 33 percent
favorable rating and they were bragging
about it when they passed it.
This is a bill that cuts corporate taxes
from 35 percent to 21 percent at a time
when corporations already paying a
historically low percentage of the tax
burden and it raises taxes on everybody
that makes $75,000 a year or less over a
10 year period.
I mean you couldn't get a piece of
legislation that spits in the face of
working people more than that,
but the saddest thing is
this guy is so comically easy to beat,
but the Democrats can't get their shit
together because they're fighting back
against the grassroots who care about
the issues because they're in bed with
corporations.
The Democrats are in bed with
corporations just like the Republicans
are.
So if you've got this corrupt party
establishment and they're trying to
tamper down the wing of the party,
that can actually win,
well then guess what?
You're going to keep losing to these
monsters,
these comic book villains on the right.
Don't you think that the parties
themselves,
there's a giant issue with the momentum
behind them,
the lobbyists and special interest
groups,
the embedded just sort of ecosystem that
they both carry with them for someone
new to step in and sort of represent the
actual people like yourself that have
this very clear view.
Well that's why they have so many people
that they're beholden to by the time
they get into a position where they can
even run for president,
they've all been vetted and checked and
well,
that's why they're.
There are some keys here.
So one of the most important things is
when you look at a politician who's
running thing,
number one is check.
Do they take corporate PAC money?
If the answer's yes,
fuck,
I'm not interested.
If you don't take corporate PAC money,
that means okay,
at least I know you're being honest and
you're being open and when you talk I
can believe you.
But if the problem comes along that
successful politician,
someone who could actually possibly when
they do take corporate pac money,
but there are a better alternative than
say a,
you know,
pence.
If pence shirts to be present after then
you go,
okay,
we've got to choose the lesser of two
evils.
That's essentially what we did with
Hillary,
right?
That's right.
And I get into that weird position
where,
yeah,
she's kind of corrupt,
but look,
she's going to be historic.
She's a woman.
She's infinitely more qualified than him
and he had the Lesser Evil Ism thing is
a,
is a big issue because that's the game
that's played on the American people.
And I think Americans know that it's
being played on them.
You know,
like if you look at the um,
the opinion polls on Congress,
Congress oscillates between a 14 percent
approval rating and a 21 percent
approval rating and what's supposed to
be a democracy.
So in other words,
you vote these people in and then two
weeks later you go ask people,
Hey,
what do you think of the Congress?
You just voted in?
And like 14 percent of them are like,
I think they're good.
Everybody else was like,
fuck them.
So we all know that there's a problem
here.
And the root of the problem is the
corruption of the system.
And the corporate money flooding our
politics and then the politicians get in
there and all they do is represent the
corporations and they don't represent
the people.
So to your point,
yeah,
in order to rise up through this system,
that's why they.
That's why the establishment loved
Hillary Clinton because she played by
the rules in this corrupt system.
Did you know that?
Her and bill through their entire
career,
they raised over $3,000,000,000 in
private donations.
That's hilarious.
And that's how you get to the point
where it was wall to wall.
Obviously she's going to win.
This is a no brainer and everybody loves
her.
I know everybody loves her on Fucking
Wall Street and in Washington DC.
But.
And again,
this to go back to the Bernie Sanders
point,
now we're seeing more politicians coming
up that are
in his model where they say,
I'm not gonna.
Take any corporate PAC money I have.
I don't even want a super PAC.
If I run for president.
And then what happens is people know at
the end of the day I can trust that
person even if I don't agree with that
person.
And that's why Bernie Sanders is the
most popular politician in the country
by a mile and a half.
He's the most popular by a long shot.
And the reason is there are even many
people on the right who look at him and
go,
you know what,
I don't agree with them on abortion.
I don't agree with him on this or that,
but I trust the guy and I think he's
fighting for me.
Well,
there's definitely that.
I mean there's,
he's,
he's a guy that really has a clean
record in terms of like the money that
he's taken.
That alone is very unique and that alone
makes him stand out from the other
people that were running for president.
When you look at the future though,
like who?
Other than him.
And I think the problem with him is
he's,
he's another one.
He's not a good health.
He's a thousand years old.
We could just say it.
It's also,
well,
there's people that are his age that are
in very good shape.
Like how old is he?
Uh,
75,
four,
seven.
Jamie,
can you check that?
My friend Aaron Snyder had a podcast the
other day with a gentleman who's 78
years old who goes on backpacks,
solo,
alcance,
any rides,
holy mountain bikes and exercises and
does all this shit.
Like there are people out there that are
his age that take care of their body,
but the problem with Bernie,
76,
76 sit somewhere in the middle of his
sternum.
He's got.
He's going Dr. posture like he looks
like a Schlubby slumpy sort of unhealthy
person,
doesn't he?
And I know that's not unimportant,
but it is kind of important to people.
You want some?
Yeah.
You're saying the optics of it matter to
an extent.
Sure.
I mean out there.
Well there are.
There are a few good politicians.
So for example,
Rocana is a positive.
She's actually from California.
He's a congressman.
I want the name.
He has risen usual.
He's risen through the ranks.
Star Trek Guy.
Well he's a bad ass.
He's a bad ass.
So know I could maybe hook up if you
wanted to have him on the podcast.
I'll talk to them and see if he'd be
willing to come on.
I think he would,
but um,
he's a,
he's a young guy.
And how old really smart guy.
I don't know exactly how old he is,
but he's,
he's young.
You have to be,
what,
39 or something to run for Congress.
I'm 35.
Jamie,
check that fact to our presidents.
30 presidents.
Thirty five.
There you go.
That's so young.
I was retarded when I was retarded.
Now when I'm 30,
I'm so fucking stupid.
When I was 35.
How can you allow people to be 35 years
old and run for president?
Yeah.
So crazy.
But I mean at the same time,
I'm sure there are some people who can
do the job,
but anyway,
back to Rocana.
Rocana.
Um,
he's a bad ass.
He's,
he doesn't take any corporate PAC money.
He's got a great record of fighting for
the people.
He's one of the few people who remember
when we were talking about going to
Syria and doubling down on doing in
Syria.
Will trump recently announced we're
staying
there indefinitely.
So we have a permanent military
occupation in Syria.
Rocana is one of the very few voices in
Congress.
I mean,
all the Democrats should be out there
saying,
what the fuck are we doing here?
Let's get out of what the.
What's the point of being there?
Rocana was one of the few who actually
spoke up about it and actually said,
no,
this is crazy.
Number one,
we shouldn't be there.
Number two,
we haven't even had a vote on it and
congress.
The whole idea is if you go do a
military intervention according to the
constitution,
you have to get a declaration of war
from Congress and real constantly.
This is crazy.
We're nowhere near abiding by the
constitution here.
We have to at least have a vote on it.
He's one person.
Tulsi Gabbard is another politician
who's fantastic,
who is a weird names.
Let me see this real kind of person
first.
Let me see what they look like.
I'm going to give him the sniff test.
This is how Americans do it,
and look at a man.
I don't know about this guy.
Show him Tulsi.
Gavin,
I'm very curious what you going to say
about Tulsa?
You average.
Let me go with the person first.
Sure.
Yeah.
My first guest on spelling didn't pull
up what I was o k h a n n a.
that's one name.
That can't be one name as the first row
was the first name.
Khan is the last name.
What's his first name?
So it caught me off guard.
Fuck Outta here.
With that,
let me see what it looks like.
He's from a silicon valley.
How do you say it's silicon or silicon?
Silicon now you're confusing me.
I think I say silicon.
I don't know if that's right though.
Well,
yeah,
he uh,
that fucking name.
I don't know about that name.
But then again saying Obama got elected
president.
We
scrutinize this fellow.
Hm.
Well,
we got a lot of good things here going.
First of all,
the diversity factor is high.
It's off the charts,
but what I love about Roe is that he
doesn't do the fake bullshit identity
politics of like,
I'm not white,
therefore,
you know,
I'm great.
He does.
In fact,
he's one of the very few politicians who
regularly speaks up about people in the
middle of the country who got their
fucking factory jobs outsourced because
corporations wanted to make more money
and he's against all these trade deals
and said Dork with the tee shirt on.
Fired up.
Ready for row,
dude.
Okay.
I need you.
I need you to just rethink your life.
That looks like a yellow shirt.
A young fatter.
Mario Lopez to the right too.
Doesn't it?
A little bit.
Sorry Mario.
No offense.
Was that him with Ted Kennedy down there
in the lower right hand corner?
Yeah,
but I think that split screen Asian.
Ted Kennedy.
I'm sorry,
whoever that person is.
But in the tiny screen it did look like
Ted Kennedy before you build it up.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this guy show him Tulsi Gabin.
See?
So He's a congressman in California?
Yes.
Alright.
Yeah,
yeah.
Tulsi tea.
You one of the people that's being
thought of as a possible Democratic
candidates because a lot of people are
talking right now about.
No,
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you who's going to run in 20,
20 copra.
Okay.
No disrespect to you,
Oprah,
if you happen to see this,
but fuck off.
No,
no disrespect to you.
The Rock.
But fuck off.
Tulsi is kind of how I.
that's like you going to say that?
That's what I kept insisting you show
from Hawaii.
I think so.
Two things.
I liked both of those things,
but so for,
in 20,
20,
a little too hot,
let me see.
Closing on her.
Make her a little larger.
Organist spoken.
Tells me your chances are very pretty.
She's a beautiful woman.
I mean is America ready for a beautiful
woman to run for president with all her
boyfriend?
She's a brilliant woman and but she's
also beautiful.
So it takes no corporate PAC money also
as against all these unnecessary regime
change wars.
So I think she's also goes to spin class
also does box jumps,
but 20 slash 20 show the military.
She was.
Yes.
Interesting.
That's a good.
That's a positive.
You got a lot of those little colored
things on our shirt and again,
she's one of the strongest voices
against.
Go into Syria and all that,
you know,
will also had a lot of those things on a
shirt.
L,
Ron Hubbard.
Remember the car?
That guy was fucking.
I don't think his were legit though.
I'm going to go out on a limb.
Yeah,
she looks.
She looks good.
I like it.
So,
um,
for 20 slash 20,
I'll tell you who's going to run.
Bernie's going to run again.
He is.
Yes he can.
He do that?
Who's going to run?
He'll be 78 years old.
He's riding a fucking wave though.
I'm on Gh.
I've been lifted.
I'm going to try to straighten my leg.
Go.
I tried to pull it back up into this
position.
I got one of those things.
It hangs from the door.
I'm stretching my neck.
He's like Larry.
Larry.
David,
right?
It looks like Larry.
David.
Yeah.
What about Oprah?
Oprah's not running bullshit.
She's not running.
She's gonna run.
I'm calling her right now.
She's nine months now.
She's not running.
She's running.
Well,
that'd be fodder for us to laugh at for
a long time.
I don't know man.
She might win.
No fucking NBC.
Whoever the Dork is that was running the
NBC twitter that was saying our
president,
like they about Oprah.
That yeah,
no,
and Oprah gave that speech.
That was at the Golden Globes.
She gave this big giant game and
everybody was like,
she's got a vagina.
Let her talk,
and she,
she's keeping me listen.
Big powerful speech.
Hollywood is so fucking insular.
They love sniffing their own farts and
suck in their own Dick clueless actress.
Stacey Dash is running for Congress in
California.
Stacey dash is like a Republican.
She's like a hard time.
She was on Fox News.
Trump supporter.
Republican.
Yeah,
she was from.
Oh,
clueless.
The movie.
They meant.
Not that she's clueless.
I read it wrong.
Maybe she is clueless to,
but stacey dash is like super hardcore.
Oh yeah.
Super Hardcore Republican Fox
commentator known for controversial
opinions.
So Oprah.
Oprah.
No,
not right now.
I'm telling you.
I'm telling you,
the Edmund's going to be the first man.
The Rock not running.
Mark Zuckerberg wants to run,
but he might not run.
Why don't you think he'll run?
Is He old enough?
He's said he's old enough,
but like getting in under the wire.
How fucking goofy is that guy,
man?
I mean goofy.
He's showed a picture of him like
fucking feeding a lamb or some shit.
He did an okay to fetal lamb.
What's wrong with this person?
I'm anti lamb feeding.
I'm taking a strong stance on the Joe
Rogan.
Someone wants lambs to starve to death
tune in secular talk podcast.
I'm mark Zuckerberg.
He's been doing this goofy Torah where
he goes to Iowa and pretends to eat with
regular people and he's like,
I spoke to a guy named Ted today and he
has a interesting story.
Hmm.
I hate the pandering.
Where they to.
That's the thing,
like when they bring up the personal
stories in there,
like pretending to care about some
random dude in Kentucky.
It's like,
fuck off.
Just tell me what your ideas are.
You don't have to do the fake empathy
shit.
Right,
right,
right.
Uh,
so I don't think he's going to run even
though he wants to because he'll get his
ass handed to him.
Mark Cuban is another guy with a giant
ego who's thinking about it,
but I don't think he'll end up doing it.
I don't think they want that scrutiny.
Like,
yeah,
a lot of shit comes out.
Yeah.
I mean,
think about who trump was.
Preelection and trump is now.
Before the election,
he was kind of lovable.
He's like this lovable egomaniac.
Weirdo guy.
He had the election.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
let me take that back because it was all
that birther shit that was pretty wacky,
but pre birth or shit,
he was the guy who played the role of
the.
I'm the big boss,
corporate sky.
Skye.
I'm the state.
It was a bigger than life character.
Large hair,
big fucking name on the buildings.
Gold,
gold lettering everywhere.
Gold bathroom,
gold toilet paper like you.
Does he not know that there's such a
thing is as.
What's the word I'm looking for?
Garish.
Does that garrison?
Yeah,
I don't think he does know that well.
He's old man with old people.
That was like someone said it best and
it's one of my favorite quotes about
trump that he is what a poor person
imagines a rich person would be like.
That's a great point.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and he's a.
he's a dumb person's idea of a smart
person because he's very confident.
Any mosts and like you say,
gold fucking everything.
It's almost,
it's almost like a rapper's more
stuntin.
Oh Yay.
I got my role's bitch.
You're going to be trump.
Is that your grill?
Paul was showing all your rings.
You're in front of your Lamborghini.
Bunch of girls shaking their booty in
front of you.
How did grills ever become a thing?
How did they not become a thing?
Why don't I have one?
That's the real question.
We were going to get what?
Paul wants better reached out to us.
We to hook us up.
You could actually maybe make girls
popular.
I don't think so.
I'm doing a good job with fanny packs
though.
I'm telling you that.
Oh,
sales are up.
Sales are up.
I'm pretty sure if fanny packs are back.
You know what?
I haven't given up on cell phone holder.
I saw that,
yeah,
I saw those people gave up on that a
long time ago.
No,
make fun of me,
but I'm like,
fuck you.
It's coming back in style and I'm
rocking it.
Somebody had a really funny joke.
I forget who it was.
I wish I could give them credit,
but it was something along the lines of,
that's the type of black guy that's
unthreading to why people type black guy
that wears a cell phone holder or the
outside buckle clip cell phone holders
just don't have him wear it around a cop
because they might think it's a gun.
Right?
Don't reach for it.
Don't reach for anything.
Um,
yeah.
The um,
the grill thing,
I dunno.
Um,
I think a gold tooth be kind of fly like
one was maybe a fang or golfing kiss.
I think that they think it shows status,
but in reality it shows in attempt to
hit higher status.
You know what I mean?
Well,
it's like that Jay z song,
99 problems,
but a bitch ain't one.
You know,
if you grew up with those holes and use
apatow's,
you'd celebrate the minute you have doe,
right?
So critics you can kiss my little
asshole.
So when you don't grow up with much,
then you're like,
I'm going to fucking get a lot and then
I'm going to show off that I have a lot.
So you know,
I got this shit.
It's a giant part of the culture.
I mean,
and even in the more reserved people
ignazio like who's like a more lyrical
artist type character.
Father was a jazz musician.
He drives a Mercedes and pictures in
front of the nice things.
It's just a part of the whole culture.
You gotta gotTa have Nice Shit.
You can't be living in a log cabin
spitting out rap music.
Nobody wants to hear anybody from like
a.
what's that show?
Life below zero.
The show where they all in Alaska,
Alaska.
Nobody wants those people rapping,
but I feel like if somebody does that,
then that for that person who really is
about the art of what they're doing.
Yeah.
You know what?
I know it's not going to happen.
No one's going to listen to a fisherman
wrap like a dude who's like salmon
fishing commercial,
like one of those dudes from a deadliest
catch.
If one of those guys had like when
they're,
you can't,
can't be a rapper.
He smell like fish.
You got to be clean.
You have to have gold teeth or
something.
You have to have a grill.
That's a is Paul Wall.
All he lost a lot of weight.
It looks good.
That beard fake.
Um,
I think it's just trimmed.
Why do you think it's fake?
Because it looks too good.
It looks like I'm not hating because I
sound like a hater.
I just ferment gel the shit out of my
hair.
So it looks like he puts her just from
anjell on that baby.
Um,
I don't know.
He might've might've darkened up is
Paul.
I feel your pain man with the.
I've been dying my hair since I was 18.
How pathetic is that?
Your hair started going gray at 18.
18.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know and I have no idea if it
was genetics or if it's stress or
whatever the fuck are you under stress.
I don't,
I mean no,
not any more than a guy who has to
fucking go to a coal mine or some shit.
I'm privileged compared to most people.
So.
No,
I don't think so.
I think,
I think it might just be genetics.
I'm not sure,
but it's working for yourself is a
little difficult though,
right?
Like not having a steady paycheck where
you have to.
And you were also involved in the
youtube demonetization wave that hit
after that pooty pie.
Cocksucker decided it was a good idea to
use the n word on a video game streams.
Well just for the record when I was an
awkward young white boy who used it to,
but with an a at the end,
not an er,
there's a big difference to throw
around.
Just throw it around,
like singing along to lyrics.
If I sing it along to the lyrics,
I roll my window up first at a respect.
Right.
And then you do.
And then I just sort of mouth it like.
Yeah,
I don't really say it out loud.
So in the rap songs,
yeah,
I of course I did.
Did it in the rap songs,
but also just being an awkward,
a young white boy from Shell and having
a lot of black friends growing up and we
just throw it around like nobody's
business.
What year were you in newer show?
Uh,
so I'm born and raised there.
So I was born in 88 and you know,
in probably when I was 20 is when I left
there.
Dude.
So when I was living in new Rochelle,
you were living in new Rochelle because
I was living there and like 91.
That's when I lived there.
Okay.
But now I'm going to make you laugh
because I was just talking to car and on
the way here about this.
So I feel like I have a memory of being
a kid watching fear factor.
You're on it.
And then I was so young that my mom
after it was like,
okay,
it's bedtime honey.
Wow.
And I'm like,
I was a little fucking kid watching Joe
Rogan and now I'm doing this podcast.
Well that totally makes sense because
that show was 16 plus years ago.
Right?
Two thousand one.
I want to say two or one,
maybe two.
Let me ask you a question about when you
were doing that show,
did you feel cause you,
you're a really smart guy and you're
interested in a lot of different things
and you.
I can tell just by talking to you,
you're somebody who needs to pave your
own path and be your own boss and it's
clear.
So did you feel like almost like a caged
animal when you were doing fear factor
because like you had to,
you were forced to show up at a certain
time every day and no,
I felt lucky that I had a job where it
can make a shitload of money.
Was that your first?
No,
you had news radio before that I had
news radio which was extremely,
extremely fortunate.
I mean that you couldn't.
I couldn't have stepped in shit any
deeper than with news radio.
It was just total luck.
I literally had like three acting
classes ever because I had to take them
because Disney gave me a development
deal because of a just stand up and they
just throw money at you and say do
something.
In the nineties they were doing that
because they had seen what happened with
Rosanne.
They had seen what happened with Tim
Allen and Seinfeld and like,
that's what you gotta do you gotta find
someone that you think is funny and
develop show around them,
and it worked with some people.
Brett Butler out a show.
There was a lot of that going on and so
they were trying to do that and so I had
a development deal and then I had to
show that it was on,
on Fox for a few episodes and it got
canceled and then I got on Newsradio.
So I'm on news radio.
Six years into my standup career I was
literally a beginner in terms of
standup,
like have you talked to a standard six
years considered a beginner,
you said?
Yes.
That's a beginner.
Yeah.
You don't know what the fuck you're
doing.
I took a guy on the road with me
recently.
They had been doing comedy for seven
years and he's got 20 minutes material.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
It's fucking to go rind son Nez.
Other people like more advanced,
like Tony Hinchcliffe seven years in had
already done a Netflix special.
Wow.
Yeah,
I mean it really varies.
It varies.
In comedy,
you feel more is like your baby than any
of the acting stuff,
right?
Oh yeah.
Well the acting stuff was just an
opportunity to make money and it was
just.
It was also an opportunity to get people
to come see you do standup,
but it was weird like to all of a sudden
be acting with Phil Hartman and Andy
Dick and Stephen Root.
Maura Tierney is like,
I don't even.
I shouldn't even be here.
Well,
how the fuck do you think?
I feel sitting across from Joe Rogan if
we're just talking.
I know,
but it's nice.
I mean that is true.
It all becomes normal man.
I mean,
I still get weirded out when I meet
famous people that I really like put
who?
I mean,
there obviously are people who are,
you know,
like Jack Nicholson for example,
is way more famous than you,
but like there's not many people.
You're almost,
are you able,
would you say you're a.
no,
no.
I'm like a c list person.
Yeah.
I don't act.
I'm not on TV.
I'm c list and I'm going to cage
fighting commentator,
you know,
it's pretty easy to dismiss me.
Yeah,
I'm more the list.
I just,
a lot of people your age know wham.
It's a different worry buddy.
My Age knows who you are.
It's different,
different world.
But uh,
so the fear factor thing was I had done
a lot of stuff after news radio that
didn't work.
Not a lot of stuff,
but a few pilot scripts that I had
gotten,
a few meetings that I had with people
that were kind of goofy.
There was a lot of like,
and I didn't,
I loved working with my,
my cat might cast my friends from news
radio.
They were great,
but I had also worked with a bunch of
actors who were actors that said,
it's not an environment,
it's not a job that lends itself to
authenticity.
It's a job that lends itself to
conformity because you're always
auditioning for things,
so you want everybody to like you,
so you sort of pattern your likes and
dislikes,
your behavior patterns,
your,
your opinions to what you lick your
finger and put it in the air.
Whereas the wind blowing,
I'm going that way.
That's the safest way to make a living.
And there's a lot of that in Hollywood.
I was going to say,
that gets back to my point about how
insular they are,
how everybody in Hollywood like,
yeah,
Oprah,
20,
20 is fucking great means.
Who the fuck is sitting in Kentucky?
Like can we go over?
We have a great ride.
Yeah.
Well maybe somebody,
maybe some men struggling with wrestling
with menopause.
Maybe some stops all xanax out.
Sitting there like drinking wine with
her husband pays the shit he says he
does.
Um,
so when fear fact came along,
two things,
I thought one was going to be cancelled
immediately.
I was really convinced and went on
forever,
forever.
One hundred and 48 episodes.
Then we came back and did seven more.
Um,
but the,
I'm getting attacked by dogs and make
people eat,
eating bold dicks.
I was like,
this is no way this is going to last.
It's crazy.
And so I felt,
I felt like at the very least it would
give me some material and it was,
it was a generous amount of money and it
was money that I was like,
okay,
if I do this and I keep doing this,
I don't have to do other things like I
can be free.
And that having that ability to say no
to things and have fuck you money and to
just not worry about how to pay your
bills.
I knew when I lived in new Rochelle is
actually when I got my first development
deal and when I got my first
development,
there was this,
this physical weight left lip lifted off
of me where I didn't have to worry,
how am I going to pay my rent next
month?
How am I going to pay my gas,
how am I going to share?
Because that was a.
I went from that to having some money
and the feeling that I got,
I was like,
oh,
okay,
this is valuable.
This is some bullshit idea like having
my.
I'm not saying that being rich makes you
happy.
It's not,
but having resources is a valuable thing
and having the resources to not have to
do something you don't want to do and
where you can pursue what you want to
do,
that's valuable as well.
So it's funny you bring that up because
I covered a study that came out a few
weeks ago on my show and I'm apparently
researchers found out that when you can,
you hit a certain level of happiness
when you hit $75,000 a year because I
think they figured out that that's where
people can generally pay the bills and
be okay.
And then they said,
uh,
if you make up to 95,000,
you do see a noticeable increase in
happiness when you jumped from 75,000 to
95,000.
So that's when people pretty much across
the board are like,
okay,
I'm good.
And then everything after that you're
playing with house money.
So they say,
you know,
the difference between making $95,000 a
year and a million dollars a year,
even though there's a big material
difference there in terms of how much it
buys your happiness it,
there's a tapering effect when you hit
that $95,000 threshold.
I think also the amount of work that you
have to do to make a million dollars a
year significantly stresses you out.
You don't have time to do things that
you love,
like say if you,
you know,
you have some hobbies that you really
enjoy.
You feel like I got to leave those alone
for awhile.
I got to pursue my career and go after
my career and really make it happen.
Yeah,
it's hard to balance that life.
Comfort in appreciation for your just
your existence here and trying to make a
living and sometimes people get that way
wrong and they go all in on making a
living and then you become some fucking
Harvey Weinstein Guy who's just all
about just vices and just filling your
life up with things that try to make you
happy because you've got $500,000,000 in
the bank and you're constantly working
and you just set a good example.
Harvey Weinstein is a good example
because he's shit fucking people in gas
and whatnot.
Electric.
Um,
the,
the better example would be someone who,
uh,
works.
So they have a heart attack and then
realizes they never had any fun.
And now their health has deteriorated so
radically that they,
they can't have fun and then they can't
work and they can't even do what they
do.
And then they have to sort of reboot
their life.
I mean,
I just think it's very important to
enjoy your time here.
It's fucking fleeting.
Like Kevin Smith.
Just A.
I saw that.
Yeah.
I love that guy.
He's a great guy.
Because you've been on the podcast a
couple times.
I've been on his.
He's been on this one a couple times.
He's awesome.
He's just a sweet,
genuine sweetheart of a guy.
He's one of those guys where if he
doesn't like someone,
I don't like them.
So like you trust him
that much.
His judgment.
Sure.
If Kevin Smith doesn't lie,
he's a really nice guy.
Like if he doesn't like you,
you must be a shit.
It just doesn't make any sense.
And you know this.
But my point is that this is fleeting.
It doesn't,
you know,
I'm 50 years old.
I became 50 years old.
I don't know how that happened.
It just keeps happening.
Well,
it's funny,
I just turned 30.
I just turned 30 on January 31st.
It was the first birthday where I ever
went,
Ooh.
Yeah,
I remember 30 shit just got a little
real.
I remember 30 because I was dating a
girl was kind of a Twat.
She was just kind of living and not her
fault.
She's a little negative.
She was like,
I already thought you already worth 30.
I'm like,
what the fuck does that mean?
I was telling you something's weird and
you're not even.
You're not even thinking about my
perspective.
I thought you already worth 30.
What is that what you're saying?
I looked through what bitch?
What are you saying?
That's a weird thing to date for like a
surface thing,
like,
oh,
I think the person is older.
I think the person is worth a lot of
money or I think that's what it was.
The shoes.
A deeply unhappy person that was trying
to diminish me.
Well,
it happened.
Not a healthy relationship now.
It wasn't a healthy relationship period,
but there's a lot of.
Lot of that happens in relationships,
right?
People try to diminish each other or
they feel like they're in a bad position
of power,
like they feel like they don't have the
power in the relationship,
so then they see that there's possibly a
vulnerability and instead of like
soothing that person,
they attack that vulnerability.
That's how you know you're in a terrible
toxic.
Their power struggles share.
Oh yeah man.
That's the worst.
It becomes a weird Machiavellian fucking
game.
Yeah.
And it's like,
well,
the whole idea of a relationship is
supposed to be.
That's where you go to get away from the
bullshit of everything.
So when that becomes part of the
bullshit,
it's like,
what the fuck are we doing here?
What are we doing?
He will probably get addicted to that
cycle there for a fucking for sure did
man it.
But it's hard to tell people while it's
happening.
It's hard to tell people,
hey man,
you're in a bad relationship.
Like this is not good.
Like especially like rich guys with hot
girls that like,
don't worry,
it doesn't make any sense.
And the was like miserable and you're
like,
hey man,
do you see what's happening?
This is not your money,
it's not gonna work,
man.
It's fucking sucks,
right?
For that rich guy was kind of a dork.
He's like,
well,
what the fuck did let you know what else
sucks when the antelope has a limp that
sucks,
and the lions running Adam and they're
in a God damn thing they could do.
The universe does not care about
whatever this imbalances,
but you as a thinking cognitive species
like you as a conscious aware
individual,
you got to pay attention to that.
Like she's going to get your money or
she's going to leave,
but either something's happening,
something's happening.
So,
uh,
going back to the point you made about
the rat race of life and people who get,
like obsessed with work and stuff like
that.
Here's an interesting fact that nobody
talks about it.
I don't know why people don't think it's
a bigger deal,
but did you know that the United States
is the only developed country that
doesn't have paid time off by law?
Every other modern countries.
You go to Europe for example,
they asked why we win bro Jesus.
So we have people who were on pills and
shit talking to me about losers,
Gordon Gekko loser countries,
and you say,
why aren't we like these losers,
those assholes with healthcare and
fucking vacation?
I definitely think people should get
paid time off.
And I definitely think,
I mean I've,
I've had some pretty intense arguments
with wealthy people about a living wage
and I'm like,
you're out of your fucking mind if you
think someone should be working for less
than $15 for an hour of their time.
So I'm telling you,
a guy's going to go in your backyard,
he's going to dig a fucking hole for an
hour.
You want to give him $5?
How much do you want to give them?
You want to give him $7?
Well Joe,
that's a market and they need to be able
to make contracts free of government
intervention.
Then I don't care for 12 years old,
12 year old,
a 12 year old digs for an hour,
give them 20 bucks.
This is crazy.
I mean the number is crazy and people
will.
The businesses won't be able to survive.
And that's just not true.
It's not true.
The person who is making the most money
at the top of the business won't make as
much money as they.
Exactly.
In fact,
whenever people bring that point up,
oh,
we can't raise the minimum wage because
of reasons and stuff and things.
I always bring up Australia.
I'd like to point out that I made.
I know Jack Shit about economics.
Okay.
I know a little bit more than Jack Shit.
But if you look up the minimum wage in
Australia,
Jamie,
I think it's like $17 in change.
They pay you in boomerangs over there,
bro.
Kangaroos,
they give you a bucket of poisonous
snakes.
Hey,
good luck.
So I think it's like $17 and change and
it's not.
They didn't look at that.
And are they,
are they a hellscape?
Joe Is Australia all bullshit aside?
I think Australia is fucking amazing.
So spare me with the bullshit arguments.
I can't afford to pay people a living
wage.
Read this.
The fair work commission has handed down
its annual ruling on Australia's minimum
wage,
raising it by two point four percent to
$672 and seventy cents a week.
That's excellent.
So means that extra 15 point a $15,
eighty cents per week for the one point
$8 million workers who are paid the
minimum wage will apply from July first
and equates to a minimum hourly rate of
$17 and seventy cents.
And that's in 2016.
May Thirtieth of 2016.
That's an excellent 7:25 here.
Did you know that the raising the
minimum wage here today is actually
worth less than the minimum wage was
worth in 1968 because if you account for
inflation,
the minimum wage from 1968 would be
about $10 in change today.
So people who are in the minimum wage
today make less than they made in 1968.
I believe it.
What do you think that is?
Do you think that's people just taking
advantage of poor people?
Is it they are they?
Do they really believe this is a
stepping stone position?
That no one who's making minimum wage
should ever consider this something
they're going to do forever.
So I don't think that it's bad people.
I don't think it's bad individuals who
are trying to take advantage of people.
I think the problem is the system and
the only reason why we don't have a
system like Australia does with their
minimum wage is because corporations
have bought the government.
So if you look at the polls,
80 percent of people want to raise the
minimum wage,
but we don't get that and we don't get
that because there's a tremendous amount
of money being poured into our
government from the likes of
corporations that don't want to raise
the minimum wage.
So that's the only constituent group
that has all the power and they happened
to be the only constituent group against
having a living wage.
So I think that's the general dynamic
behind it.
I do think that there are some small
businesses where they're like,
listen,
I genuinely don't have the money to do
this.
You know what I mean?
So,
uh,
for those cases,
yes,
we can have a,
a separate conversation about those
instances.
But if you're a fucking giant
corporation,
don't bullshit us and tell us you can't
afford to pay somebody a living wage
because in the case of like Walmart for
example,
they don't pay their people living wage
and then they dump all of their workers
onto the,
onto the medicaid rolls and onto the
social safety net.
So tax payers end up paying billions of
dollars to support them.
Meanwhile,
the people who are part of Walmart or
running out the back door with all the
fucking money.
Yeah,
that's real.
I mean that's kind of undeniable.
And the idea that a CEO should be able
to earn that much more money than
anybody else.
It's kind of fucking crazy to like the
whole ceo position is very bizarre.
The fact that these guys get payouts
when their companies go under and Wall
Street bailouts.
Oh God.
I mean stop and think about that for a
second because I don't think that people
really got how ridiculous that was.
So if you own a fucking Deli or you own
a dry cleaners and you go under,
you know what they say?
Tough Shit.
Take Care Buddy.
Yeah,
exactly.
But if you're a part of a big bank or
you're part of a fucking hedge fund that
made the decisions that ended up
crashing the fucking economy,
not only do you not get fired,
they say in order to retain the talent
of these people,
we're going to have to pay them bonuses
with the taxpayer money that just bailed
out the corporation that they
bankrupted.
That was hilarious.
So it wasn't just that these people got
bailed out,
which was also very arguable.
Are good position to argue against that.
Right?
Like,
I don't know what would've happened if
we let the banks fail.
I know how catastrophic that would have
been to our economy,
but it's arguable whether it was a
debatable point.
It's not a debatable point to give those
fucking people millions of dollars of
taxpayers money has gone to the bailout
so that they can get that bonus.
It's in their contract.
Correct.
And Obama was like,
well,
it's in their contracts will fuck their
contracts.
The contracts had no good now because
the whole company went under.
Your bank's fucked up.
You guys were running the banks.
You don't get that 50 million bucks you
were promised,
and here's what they don't do.
They never come out and say,
okay,
well we're going to do is a bailout of
the people who are hurt by this.
They always go,
well,
what we have to do is we have to give it
to the companies that just made the
decisions that fucked everything up in
the first place and sit down and shut up
and those guys are already rich.
That's what's even crazier.
You're giving rich people tons of money
after they fucked up and did a shitty
job and this goes back to why trump
seemed appealing to so many people is
because you have,
you know,
somebody who seems like a measured guy
and a smart guy and he said he was going
to change the game,
but then he also fucking bailed out Wall
Street and people look at that and they
go,
okay,
you know what?
Fucking anything but this.
Okay,
Forget Hillary Clinton.
Forget the status quo.
I'll take the guy who's going to break
shit.
Yeah,
I definitely think there was something
like that.
There was also that he didn't seem like
one of them.
He seemed like something different,
like let's try something different.
This is a new thing.
The old thing is not working.
This whole person who talks like this,
who gives these speeches in front of
large groups of people,
I'm going to promise you change and hope
and dignity and burn and vague words
that mean flowery things.
Noises to here.
So this gentleman,
what's his name again?
The the guy with the short name Rocana.
Rocana.
Yeah.
Row was the full name.
What's his full name?
No idea.
I just know rig back something crazy.
I mean,
how does he speak?
Speak like a politician.
He's talking like a normal dude.
He talks like a normal dude.
Can we listen?
Very honest guy.
I want to smell them out.
If you want to find a clip on youtube or
something like that.
Clip.
Let's break it down.
But I'm willing to fucking put my chips
in this guy's corner.
Well,
it's not going to run in 20 slash 20,
but he's.
He's,
Oh,
don't be a pussy.
He's on the radar.
He's got a Tan suit.
It's over.
You can't do it.
Don't you remember the Tan Suit Obama
thing?
I do.
Yeah.
To cover this event.
This is a very respectful gathering and
the purpose is very simple as I haven't
had the opportunity to campaign for over
a year and a half across this district.
The best part I think this
meeting,
check him out.
He's going after his opponent when he
was running.
If you really want to to your warning
here,
talking about Medicare,
going to get this guy on adderall.
Listen,
you've got to get them on those pills at
trump's on them,
on those fucking energy pills.
We really have like a lot,
a lot of vigor,
a lot of.
A lot of pep in your step.
You think trump's on pills 100 percent.
You think he's on adderall?
I think he's on something like that on
it.
Do really well.
Apparently there is a reporter that
literally named the pharmacy.
Where do the Duane Reed pharmacy where
trump had his prescription.
Oh Shit.
Where he used to be on one form of
amphetamine.
That was a diet pill supposed to be on
for six months.
He was on for years.
It completely makes sense.
You talked about the amount of time that
guy spent on the campaign.
70 some odd year old guy out there
giving speeches and leslie and entergy's
incredible.
Yeah,
and let me tell you something.
Everybody that I know that did adderall,
like I had a good.
I have a good friend it before.
Yeah,
I haven't,
but I have a good friend who was on it
for a long time and he got off at.
He gained 50.
He feels like it's hard
for him like he but he,
he said doctors,
we're just handing them this stuff and
that stuff and that one doctor gave him
three different amphetamines and told
him find the one that you liked the
best.
That's a heart attack waiting to happen
if you take them all at once,
jacked up on these things all the time.
And last time I saw him was like four
years ago when he was jacked up on them
and I'm like,
dude,
what's going on?
And he's like,
ah man,
these fucking on adderall.
And I go,
you kinda like out of it.
He's like,
yeah,
I just,
you know,
so he's now he's back to normal,
but he's like,
I eat anything and I gained weight.
Now the whole system's all screwed up.
What is it about some people who can't
have a little bit of something and
experienced the upsides of it without
getting totally hooked by it because
that's something I feel like that's
something that I can do.
Like I could try something and then I
can experience the upsides of it and
not,
you know what I mean?
So productivity thing.
So for example,
I brought,
I brought you,
you said you already have a budget,
but Kratom I wanted to try a Kratom
Kratom something that I have and I
always feel like it,
it's like almost like caffeine to me.
I feel like it allows me to control,
control my consciousness better.
So if I want to make a decision to do
something,
I feel like if I have Kratom in me,
I can focus on it more.
I could be more creative and it's just
upsides of it,
you know what I mean?
Is that how you feel when you smoke
weed?
Yeah.
Well,
what we eat is like a,
a bunch of different things is one of
the things that I like about weed that a
lot of people are terrified.
One of the things that people don't like
about weed is the intense introspective.
I get paranoid or yeah,
that's what it is.
But that I think is where you get
growth.
Really.
Yeah,
man.
I think that that fear.
So do I have like demons in my past that
when I,
when I smoke it,
unlike looking at that and I went away,
I don't want to psychoanalyze,
but I feel like what from my own
personal view,
if I feel bad about something,
if I smoked pot and then all sudden I
remember something I did like two years
ago,
I'm like,
why did I do that?
Like,
what was it?
What the fuck was that about?
I think that's an opportunity for
psychic growth.
It gives me an opportunity to examine my
own thoughts and try to figure out what.
What I mean like who you are at any
given time is a bunch of different
factors,
right?
It's what's going on in your career,
what's going on in your personal life,
where's your health at,
how stressed out,
how many of these factors are outside of
your control with where's your what,
what's what's the state of your success
in life and all these various things and
then all those things together and
that's who you are at any given time and
it fluctuates.
It moves,
it goes back and forth,
and if you catch yourself at a good time
and you smoke pot,
you feel great and if you catch yourself
at a point where maybe you're examining
these things,
like sometimes you'll think about these
various factors and you get very
uncomfortable and some in when you were
in a state just an hour ago where you
were super comfortable about your life.
Now all of a sudden you're don't feel
good.
Like what is that?
Well,
it's probably there's some sort of
subconscious thoughts and ideas you've
ignored and I think the ignoring those
things is probably
unhealthy and even though that feeling
of paranoia or whatever you want want to
call it,
I call it ruthless introspective
thinking.
Right?
That feeling is probably,
it's healthy because it's,
it's making you examine things that
you're probably pushing to the dark
regions of your consciousness.
You don't make them make you
uncomfortable so you push them aside and
I think they're better off explored and
dealt with.
So I feel I've always felt like
substances that either up my mood and
make me feel like I want to be very
proactive and creative and busy and
talkative,
fine with taking something like that,
fine with taking the opposite.
Something that relaxes me and makes me
feel just at ease and calm.
But I've always.
So with my limited experience with weed,
because I've only smoked,
we honestly maybe eight to 12 times in
my life,
some right now.
No.
I will fucking shit myself and realize
that there's millions of people watching
us right now and I'll realize that that
happens sometimes too.
But anyway,
so I've always had an issue with
psychoactive substances were so I've
never tried.
And all the ones that did drugs,
you talk on a regular basis like
psilocybin and stuff like that.
Um,
I'm,
I've always been scared of them.
Um,
and I always feel like the drugs that
will make me see things that aren't,
they're hallucinogenics I'm just scared
of them because I feel like I,
I'll take that trip and not come back,
you know what I mean?
I know that I'm just wanting to bringing
it up to you because I know you disagree
with that and I'm curious what you think
about why I'm scared of those because
with my experience with weed,
most of the times I smoked it,
it really was like a paranoid type.
You probably,
first of all,
we probably smoked too much.
I always did.
I'm sure I did.
I was advised people when the first time
they smoke pot just take one little hit
this,
a little hit and just experience the
good parts,
which is like a good,
weird kind of funny feeling.
And then there's also,
I feel like it's a turbo charger for
your imagination.
It's one of my favorite things that
happened,
but I,
my,
I feel like I already have a hyperactive
mind.
And then when I met the path,
my mind will go down when I smoke weed,
you know,
suddenly I'm thinking about,
I don't know,
fucking naked vikings and that's.
But like,
it's like,
well,
how the fuck am I thinking about all
this shit?
But it's like a shock to the system.
And did you um,
the first few times I smoked weed I
didn't get high.
Did that happen with you or no?
No,
no,
you gotta tie immediately.
Got Really High.
So I have a pretty funny story about
that.
I,
the first few times I smoked it,
I thought I was cool.
I was in high school.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm going to be cool kid and smoke weed.
So I smoked it and didn't have any
effect.
And then by the third or fourth time
somebody had asked me before I had
class,
uh,
you want to smoke weed?
I was like,
yeah,
fuck it.
Let's do it.
It didn't affect me the other a few
times.
Why not went and smoked it.
I opened the to come back in school and
I start walking down the hallway.
Doom,
doom,
doom.
Guy was like,
bumbumbumbum feels weird and then I'm
sitting in class,
convinced my eyes are probably bloodshot
red in my mind.
Everybody in the room knows I'm high and
they're like thinking like,
hey,
this asshole's hi,
I'm scared to death of the teacher.
So anyway.
But there was,
there was a few times where I smoked
weed and I had a positive experience,
but it was like all it was was just
giggling nonstop with my friends to the
point where we'd laugh,
laugh,
and then I remember one of us literally
asking,
Hey,
why the fuck are we laughing?
And somebody said,
I don't know.
And then we kept laughing.
Well that's,
listen,
it's a good thing to laugh.
I don't think it's a bad thing,
but one of the reasons why you don't
remember what you were laughing and
there's a real issue with short term
memory in marijuana.
You know,
it's one of the reasons why I prefer
marijuana with nootropics.
I like the combination of the two.
I think they balanced each other out
because the nootropics accentuate your
memory.
And then on top of that,
the marijuana sort of flux with your
memory a little bit.
If there's a,
there's,
there's real issues.
I mean,
marijuana is not,
it's not 100 percent innocuous in terms
of your like psychics,
stability.
Well you said when you took off the
month you had your dreams.
There were way different.
They were very,
very intense.
Like within the first week it started
getting really crazy,
like intense,
like weird lucid dreams.
Like just very,
very bizarre and detailed and bright and
vivid.
And so you think that it's one of those
things where that's not good.
So are you trying to avoid smoke weed a
little less so that you don't have the
effects on sleep?
Or do you like.
I don't think it's bad for your sleep
and red.
Is that what it.
God,
I wish I could remember.
Let's see if uh,
see if he could pull that up.
Like what?
What are the marijuana?
And there's some positive benefits to
it.
It just bypasses that rem sleep,
deep rem sleep quicker.
And you get to the deeper stages of
sleep because rem sleep a lot of people
think is like the deepest levels.
It's not,
you know,
there's a deeper level of sleep and the
idea is that marijuana somehow or
another gets you to that deeper level
quicker.
There's a lot of people that I know that
smoke pot before they go to bed and it's
very helpful.
Yeah,
That's one of the interesting things
about Kratom and why I think it's kind
of similar to weed and how people use
it.
Even though the feeling is different
when they take it,
is that many people take it because they
were addicted to opioids and it,
it helps them get off the pills and on
Kratom if you have too much of it,
you just throw it up.
If you have too many opioids,
you can die from an overdose.
And this is one of the reasons why the
FDA is cracking down on it because
they're fucking bought by big Pharma and
they don't want anything that's going to
compete with their fucking profits.
Yeah.
There's no reason to ban that.
There's no deaths.
There's no addictive.
It's not.
It's not something that's fucking people
up.
It's just not so.
People take it for a cause.
They had an addiction to pills.
People take it for PTSD,
they take it for depression and anxiety.
They take for recreational reasons,
they take it to wake up in a smaller
dose.
They take it to sleep in a bigger dose.
It's a substance like that.
That's a weird substance in terms of
like,
I don't know any other substance where
you took a low dose and it's a stimulant
you until you always take a lower dose
of opioids.
It's more of an upper.
You take a bigger dose of opioids is
more of a downer.
What's the rationalization for
categorizing it as an opioid?
Because it affects the same receptors in
the brain,
but it doesn't have the same response.
That will.
That's why that's a very.
It's a very misleading thing that the
FDA did is because what they're trying
to do is find a backdoor way to be like
that.
Sorry,
you guys can't have it because it's an
opioid and it's dangerous and it's this
and this that,
but they're glossing over the most
important point,
which is the one that we were talking
about,
which is if you take too much Graham,
you just throw up.
If that's not the case with opiates,
just white people overdose all the
fucking time and actually the bigger
problem is that when people get addicted
to opioids and then because of the
crackdown,
now they're.
They're not prescribing as many opioids.
Then those same people go to the black
market and they get fucking heroin and
then when they get a heroin on the black
market,
oftentimes it's laced with fentanyl,
which is a fucking elephant
tranquilizer,
which then kills them.
So it's killed Tom Petty and princess
here and Philip Seymour Hoffman.
They were speculating that defendant was
in his heroin,
which is why he died.
That was heroin.
Heroin,
right.
He didn't have pills.
Oh no,
it wasn't.
Yeah,
it wasn't pills.
He was doing heroin,
but the stuff that they found,
princess system,
he apparently didn't even have a
prescription for fentanyl.
Oh,
so you're saying somehow somehow or
another he got it.
I don't know.
I mean probably want something stronger.
He apparently had fucked his hips up.
Prince Prince had done all that crazy
dancing on stage and all those years,
you know,
um,
my friend maynard from tool,
he had to get a hip replacement from
stomping on stage.
You ever see like how maynard sayings
when he would sing,
he would just be fucking stomping on
stage.
He blew his hip out.
That's crazy.
Now he's got an artificial hip.
They cut the top of it.
How old is he?
Fifty 51.
Shit.
Human body.
So fucking fragile.
It is super fragile
and I'm going to have to be.
Everybody's going to be like,
shut the fuck up kyle.
You can't stop talking about Tiger Woods
because I love golf and I love Tiger
Woods.
Tiger Woods is a great example of that
guy had fucking for baxter surgeries.
Yeah,
for back surgery.
Dude.
I know a lot of people that have had
back surgery.
My good friend Eddie Bravo has an
artificial disc in his back.
Shit.
And he does.
He still do Jujitsu.
And and stuff,
he doesn't right now because he blew his
acl out.
He to have acl reconstructive surgery.
I mean,
look,
Jujitsu is rough on the body.
I've had two knee reconstructions,
one from taekwondo,
one from one from a Jujitsu.
But then I had a third operation from
Jujitsu as well.
So two knee surgeries from Jujitsu.
And I had some significant back problems
too.
Everybody gets them just,
there's no way around that.
If you're,
if you're training hard,
your body can only take so much.
And you were talking about the stem
cells that you saw,
the podcast with Mel Gibson,
with the stem cells.
How is it fascinating?
I haven't gone the Panama yet to do
that.
Um,
I've only done them in America,
which apparently you can't get the same
sort of potency,
but there's some new research that shows
that there's some,
uh,
there's some other stuff they're working
on now that is a,
this sounds gross,
but umbilical blood,
they're,
they're using blood from,
um,
from umbilicals of people that are,
you know,
like just giving birth and they're
having radical healing response with
this stuff.
Well,
there was a study that came out a few
years ago that said when you took the
blood of young mice,
Brian,
and put them into all my different
context.
Yeah.
That is a.
that's something that erroneously was
attributed to Peter Teal.
The Peter Teal was doing that.
Apparently he said he wasn't,
but there's a startup in silicon valley
that does that.
It offers and guys are going there and
so like a guy would go there and some 25
year old kid who does crossfit everyday
would give up a couple of pints of blood
and they'd shoot it into your system and
then you go out there and fuck the shit
out of your wife.
It can't be that simple.
Right?
Like that's almost too simple a concept.
They just take the blood for the young
people,
put it into the old people and
everybody's a fucking Olympic athlete
maybe.
Yes.
And maybe.
No,
I'm like a vampire too,
right?
Isn't that like the whole theory?
Little bit.
Elizabeth bathory thing,
right?
You remember the story of Elizabeth
bathory?
No,
she was.
It's interesting.
Somebody contacted me on twitter and
told me that this story might be a
distortion,
even though it's in the,
it's sort of in the historical record.
They might've actually been trying to
steal her land so they might have
fabricated some of these charges.
But one of the,
um,
the ancient stories of Elizabeth battery
was that she was this incredibly evil
woman that as she got older she would
torture and kill young peasant women and
like bathe in their blood because she
wanted to regain her youth and she was
jealous of these.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's real though.
This person who said that it was a hoax,
it was a made me go,
oh,
okay.
I could see that happening to,
you know,
where someone wanted to steal from her.
So they concocted some charges or it
could be either or.
It could be both.
You know,
who the fuck knows?
Well,
with the stem cell thing,
I feel like it should be here already if
the evidence is as solid as he was.
The doctor was saying yes and no.
Um,
the evidence is very solid that there's
some regenerative properties of stem
cells.
The problem is we don't have enough
evidence of what the potential downsides
could be and whether or not there's a
very specific protocol that ensures
safety.
Now Dr Neil Riordan is on top of all
that stuff and his books,
we used to have them sitting around
here,
but I think we put them in our little
library.
Um,
his books,
detail all of the various studies that
have shown efficacy and all the
different benefits that they have.
And for a lot of people like Mel
Gibson's dad who was two when he went in
there,
now he's almost a hundred and Mel
Gibson's dad was fucked.
I mean he couldn't walk.
He was all jacked up and it straightened
them right out.
So not to get all conspiratorial,
but it may be,
may be,
I have no idea,
but maybe the reason why it has not
already here is because there's some
preexisting treatment for stuff like
that that they don't want to scrap.
Know what I mean?
I mean,
it's always possible.
I think more likely they're skeptical.
And then the FDA also wanted to
categorize some stem cell preparations
as a drug because you have to do
something to the stem cells.
And then the,
in,
in the process of cultivating them,
there's some sort of a,
um,
a method that they do that they believe
categorizes it as a drug.
I'm obviously a moron,
so I'm not the right person telling you
about this.
But Dr Neil Riordan is lobbying to get
it passed in Texas.
God Damn Great State of Texas.
Hallelujah.
If anybody can do it,
Texas can do.
If they don't go,
yeah,
they don't care.
They don't give a fuck.
It's barely America.
That's Texas is it's own thing.
I would love it if they did that,
if they did it where you could go to
Texas and get these treatments.
Everybody that I know that it's gone
over there and gotten the treatments has
had some radical positive response.
Well,
didn't know quite a few people that have
gone there.
There are,
I know countless stories of people.
So I know somebody who got the lasik eye
surgery and they flew to the UK to get
their version of it because their
version of it is on his is better,
is superior and we have the older one
here and they're still waiting on the
approval for the new way of doing it.
Well why would they hold back approval
on that?
So it doesn't make any sense.
I don't know.
And this is what I'm saying.
I feel like in many instances,
not in every instance,
but in many instances you have to
preexisting treatments that are already
in place and there and pharmaceutical
companies make a lot of money from
having those treatments already in
place.
So if you try to upend the apple cart
overturn the apple cart,
I mean that's.
This gets back to the whole kratom
point.
There's a reason why.
If this is something that's basically a
cure for addiction to opioids,
why the fuck are we not pushing it like
crazy?
And the reason is they don't want to
start making money off the fucking
opioids.
That is,
I think that is a much more likely
conspiracy because there's just an
ungodly amount of money and opioid.
Yeah,
so look at the pill mills and fucking
West Virginia.
Millions of pills in a town that doesn't
have that many people.
Did you ever see the documentary,
the Oxycontin Express?
I did not know.
Oh,
actually I may.
May Have the one where they go to
Broward County.
Yeah.
I think I saw that they've changed the
law since then because people were going
to.
I mean it was one of the most ridiculous
things they've ever had in this country.
They had a setup where they had these
pain management centers,
so is one box,
right?
One building and in this building
there's two different doors.
One door is the doctor.
You go to the doctor,
go,
hey man,
I'm fucking back hurts.
And the doctor says,
okay,
I'll write you a prescription.
Go next door to the pharmacy.
The pharmacy only has oxicon.
Yeah.
It's like if you only have a hammer,
everything looks like a nail and hammer
here.
How am I going to chop this tree down?
Well guess what?
I'm going to use a hammer.
I mean it's fucking crazy that this was
going on for so long and then they also.
This is where it got really weird.
It wasn't just the of these pain
management centers,
they also didn't have a state database,
so if you went to Jamie over there and
got a prescription for Oxycontin and
then you left Dr Jamie's office with fat
bag of pills.
You could go to Dr Joe's office and I'll
give you another prescription.
These pain management centers were all
over the place in Florida,
so Florida was literally.
Because I mean there's no other way that
I could imagine that this would be done
conscientiously.
I think this is all corruption.
I think the only reason why they would
have no database.
It's not.
We're not in the 15 hundreds measure.
You guys could keep records of WHO's
fucking on this shit and who's not.
There's a way.
I mean,
they had records back before the
Internet.
This.
There's no excuse for this.
This is I think,
intentional corruption and what's crazy
is now the pendulum is swinging almost
too far in the other direction.
Ohio Attorney General Suing opiod use
distributors.
Now this is a good example of what I
think is the pendulum swinging too far
in the other direction because I have
pain patients who contact me all the
time and they talk about how since
there's new federal regulations over the
pills,
what's happening is many doctors are
afraid to prescribe them at all,
even when it's a legitimate pain issue
and so people contact me and they go,
I don't know what to do because I need
my pills because I have severe pain
problem and I've had it for an extended
period of time and nobody wants to give
me the pills anymore and they feel like
they're forced to go on the black market
now.
Right.
And,
and now that they're eliminating Kratom
it's even more fucked up.
Exactly.
So what is the status of Kratom
currently?
Still legal.
Still legal,
but it's a monitored substance by the
FDA.
What does that mean?
It basically means if they want to,
they see fucking shipments of it when it
comes into the US,
if they want,
if they want to get that shipment back.
No,
you can't get it back off,
back off.
We're going to take your beneficial
plants,
but it's still.
Thankfully it's still it still leeway.
The last time the FDA really tried to
crack down on it and make it a schedule.
One drug,
the fucking bowels of hell opened up on
their face because they opened up a
comment section,
a comments period and like 99 point nine
percent of the comments were like,
fuck you to saved my life.
You guys are fucking criminals.
How dare you do this?
And then they had to back off because
the comments were just so overwhelming.
So now they're trying to sneakily do it
again.
And what's happening is they just a
referenced,
Oh,
there were 44 cases of somebody who
overdosed from Kratom multistate
outbreak of Salmonella.
Right.
So this is related to creative.
Exactly.
So there were a few cases of Salmonella
tainted Kratom and so the idea is
another way they try to go up,
like we gotta get,
we gotta get rid of it because there is
some salmonella cases at this time.
The CDC recommends that people not
consumed Kratom in any form because it
could be contaminated with Salmonella.
We instead suggest fentanyl,
which kills rhinos.
We could kill fucking whale with a with
a altoids size piece of fentanyl.
They literally kill a whale.
I know that will be fucked.
An altoid show.
They said Doris,
they said there were 44 deaths linked to
Kratom.
Twenty eight cases.
Few people got diarrhea,
but we'll have in hospice.
That's it.
Eleven,
11 hospitalizations.
The story,
he gets crazier because there were 44
cases that the they cited and said,
well look man,
44 cases of people dying when they took
Kratom.
Guess what?
No reporters decided,
let's look into this.
Let's dig deeper and see what happened.
First of all,
one of the cases was a suicide that they
counted as a death.
They're attributing to Kratom.
That's hilarious.
Another was a homicide.
And then so now we're going on 42.
There were,
and then most of them people had like
five or six different drugs in their
system and they're saying not dad's
Kratom.
So,
well that's one of the things that they
did with marijuana and car accidents.
They were saying,
oh,
all these different car accidents.
People have marijuana in the system.
Yeah.
Well they were also a drunk.
Exactly.
Yeah.
People were partying,
man,
that they're out of their fucking head
and they crashed into trees.
So it's not good.
How do you feel now that California has
legalized it?
Is it because you had the medical one
before and now is it more of a pain in
the ass to get weed?
Because it's legalized.
It's very easy to get weed and
California.
It's very easy.
It's not as easy as in Colorado.
Colorado's got a down.
Colorado's got it nailed and they are
swimming,
swimming in money coming to the point
where they have to give people money.
That's right.
They gave a check to everybody in the
state and they take.
I love how they take a lot of the money
and they divert some of it to education,
some of it to,
to substance treatment.
So they're doing the most responsible
thing for it and like you said,
they the tax on it.
Everybody's like,
okay,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
What?
I mean it's.
It's a high tax rate.
I think they have a 39 percent tax rate
on a recreational and I think it's like
an 11 on medicinal,
but here's the thing.
It's not exorbitantly expensive.
It's a plant that grows easy.
It's not hard to grow.
It's not like some very difficult grape
that needs a perfect climate and it's
not.
Marijuana is not hard to grow,
so there's not a lot of arguments
against it for responsible adults.
Yeah,
and that's the thing is are we going to
regulate responsible adult use of
substances?
Because if we do,
we'd be hypocritical if we didn't
eliminate alcohol.
Exactly right.
One of the worst ones,
if you look,
if you look at it objectively,
you would have to say,
listen,
this substance which is legal and has
been legal for a very long time,
is actually more dangerous than many of
these ones that are illegal,
and we learned from alcohol prohibition.
How terrible and idea is to just ban the
substance because what happened during
prohibition,
the Mafia got incredibly powerful
because they're the ones selling the
alcohol.
They're the ones making the money,
and then when you have a dispute and
your product is on the black market,
you know how you solve that dispute with
fucking guns in the street.
You know,
you solve the dispute.
If it's illegal,
you go to court wearing suits and ties
and you figure it out like adults.
Well,
this is another thing that trump should
have recognized when he was sessions is
a perfect example that God is a God damn
monster.
He's an easy.
He's an old school mentality of like,
I was raised my niche wrong.
If you put substances in your body where
he literally said good people don't use
marijuana.
Well that's crazy,
bro.
Yeah,
you can stick a moral judgment on you
for that.
I think there's something like 37
percent of the country is a regular
marijuana user.
So you're saying 37 percent of the
country's bad people.
Yeah,
exactly.
And this is another example,
by the way,
have 60 percent of people now want to
legalize marijuana across the country.
So this is another issue where if the
Democrats decided,
let's not be fucking corrupt idiots and
let's actually fight for something,
do you have any idea how big of a ballou
tsunami there would be in the next
election?
If every Democrat came out there and
said one of the things were far
legalizing marijuana,
we're going to fight for it and we're
not going to take no for an answer and
we're gonna make a lot of money that can
go to the schools.
They can go to the infrastructure as
code and the job creation.
These are arguments that also appeal to
the right.
If you tell people on the right,
hey,
you guys say you love small government,
you know what's really big government
when they knocked down your fucking door
and drag you out in handcuffs because
you decided to tweak your consciousness
slightly.
Yeah,
that's the biggest government
imaginable.
They kick your door down,
shoot your dog because you've got to
fucking bowl sitting on your coffee
table.
There's so many examples of that too.
If,
if trump really wanted to stop all this
illegal Mexican cartel legalize,
legalize and tax it,
regulate it,
done thousands of jobs to create.
Exactly.
There's no reason for them to be here.
Yeah,
and that.
See,
this is one of the things that's so
frustrating to me doing what I do and
one of the reasons why I think it shows
like ours have blown up is because we're
willing to say the most obvious things
that everybody's thinking,
but the system is dragging like fucking
50 years behind what we're talking
about,
but you could never do the show that you
do or this kind of show.
If you had like real serious
advertisers,
entrepreneurs,
percent serious network and producers
and executives have.
You had a bunch of executives that were
above you and you know,
fill in the blank CNBC or whatever and
their job depended upon you.
Not saying something fucked up that was
going to get the advertisers to crack
down on their program and you wouldn't
be able to do it.
You wouldn't have freedom.
In fact,
a Janky Uber was on MSNBC.
The reason he ended up leaving MSNBC,
he was too hard on the Democrats,
so his higher ups were like,
hey listen man,
I just heard from our friends in
Washington that you need to reel it in a
little bit,
turn,
and he's like,
wait,
I don't understand.
So the whole idea of MSNBC is be
partisan,
be in favor of the Democrats and support
the democratic establishment.
The whole idea of Fox News is be
partisan support the Republican support
the establishment.
If somebody comes along and they go,
you know what?
Your whole fucking game is bullshit.
Both the are corrupt.
Nobody's fighting for the people.
You're ignoring.
The fact that only 14 percent of the
American people even support Congress.
You're ignoring the fact that 60 percent
of people want to legalize marijuana.
If you go and talk about real issues,
that's when they step up and they go,
listen,
we can't have you because you know,
hey,
you curse too much or this isn't
palatable and it's always people above
you who feel like they should be able to
control your content,
but they don't understand the reason why
the content is popular in the first
place is because you're not fucking
being controlled.
Exactly.
They they're operating in this archaic
format to.
The other problem is they interrupt
their show every 15 minutes for our
shows and it's just they break the flow
of it and then they got fucking
commercials for antidepressants and
diarrhea pills and whatever the fuck
else are selling and it's just nobody
wants that.
This is a.
it's an archaic version of entertainment
and it made sense back when.
That was the only way to get your
entertainment when the only way to get
your entertained was the big three.
NBC,
ABC,
CBS,
and Fox comes along with tosses the
apple up and then you got cable.
Oh my goodness.
Now things are crazy.
Well,
the cable news is really opened it up
and now you got wild shit like Fox News
and all this and Meghan Kelly doesn't
have any clothes on.
She's telling you about fucking history.
All that stuff was really an interesting
thing.
Then the Internet comes along,
all bets are off 100 percent and they're
fuck because a guy like you mean who?
Who's.
Who's involved in your operation?
How many people?
Three,
four.
Sylaria.
Yeah.
Hi,
Bill with Lilith.
Those a lot of stuff.
She's awesome and yeah,
I mean that's,
that's,
that's nuts.
I mean how many fucking people would be
involved in the Ryan seacrest show?
Forget it.
And hundreds.
Right?
And the fact that when you keep
something,
Ryan seacrest.
Yeah,
he's so irrelevant.
And will you keep something small and
close to the chest?
I feel like that's when you can mold it
and make it your own.
When it becomes a giant big operation at
43 hands are in it,
well then all of a sudden it feels like
it's stale and detached and not
connected to anything real that people
can relate to.
Now I've been involved in that kind of
stuff before.
I know what happens.
Just there's too many cooks in the
kitchen.
Everything gets fucked up and everybody
is also trying to justify their
position,
which is almost unnecessary.
I mean there's so many positions when
you.
When you work on a television set and
you see how many people are just
standing around and you go,
oh,
what the fuck is,
why are there so many jobs?
Like why there's so many people working
on.
A lot of it is like they've kind of
created these jobs,
justify their position and then when
there's meetings,
those people all have like an idea that
they want change.
They want to change this or tweak that,
and so they can say that was my idea and
that justifies the real.
Well,
it was my idea to tell kyle that he's
got to stop doing this and start doing
that and we got kyle to wear a suit and
he pushed back,
but I was right.
I was right.
You know,
like there's all that kind of shit that
happens on these Goddamn TV sets and it
ruins the,
the individual idea,
like a person's individual point of
view.
Like if there's no way you're going to
get a real unique individual point of
view if you have so many people tweaking
and adjusting and restricting and,
and demanding that a person behave a
certain way or dress a certain way or
stay to a certain topic or you know,
keep on,
you know,
you have to keep within these very
clearly defined parameters.
Where was it a worst for you?
Which show was it the man show when you
did the man show?
I was asked.
Yeah,
that was a disaster for a bunch of
reasons,
but one of the reasons why that was a
disaster was because Janet Jackson and
Justin timberlake decided to pull
Janet's booby out on TV.
Oh,
and so they cracked down,
so it'd be policing.
They were terrified of everything,
but that's also,
you have a bunch of people again,
that aren't comedians.
They don't know what's funny and they're
trying to impose their idea of what's
funny and what's not.
You have a lot of that on television
now,
you have a lot of these people that
aren't necessarily comedians,
but they might be like super progressive
social justice warrior types and now
they're trying to push that kind of
comedy is being what everybody likes and
then that shit gets to,
you know,
Jamie's hometown,
Columbus,
Ohio,
and these people are like,
what the fuck?
Exactly.
Eating me.
And then meanwhile,
like we were talking about for the
podcast,
a guy like joey diaz comes around and
everybody's like,
that's it.
That's what we want you to know this guy
on in the world.
He's a perfect example too because for
the longest time I was trying to tell
people for the longest time,
like I had agents,
former agents of mine that would tell
me,
you've got to stop working with them.
That's literally the dumbest Shit I've
ever heard in my life is not fun and
it's so easy to see.
He's like a diamond in the rough in how
unique he is and how just
straightforward he is.
Yeah,
he's a genius.
He's a comedy genius.
I think he's the funny in terms of like
bursts of,
I might not be the very best joke writer
of all time,
but in terms of being the funniest,
I think he's the funniest person that's
ever lived.
I've seen everybody.
I've seen almost everybody either live
or on video.
I don't think anybody's ever been
funnier than Joey.
I've seen joey some nights at the Ice
House or some nights at the comedy
store.
Hit levels of ridiculousness.
I don't think I've seen anybody and his
whole thing.
He's a God damn human cartoon.
Says Voice is cartoon.
Listen,
dog says way moves and forever.
They were telling me that that guy is
not funny.
This is not good.
This guy can't work and he wasn't
getting work other than like character
work in movies,
but then the internet came along and
then people got to know him on podcasts
and that's what really made Joey and you
knew that.
Everybody who is telling you that was
working backwards from their conclusion
that they had this idea in their mind of
what somebody who's popular is supposed
to be.
Yeah.
He didn't fit that mold because he's too
rough around the edges and he curses too
much and he talks about eating ass and
all that shit,
and then you knew.
No,
I know innately I look at this guy and
he,
he touches something in me so I know
this is going to connect with other
people while I'm also.
I'm out there in the clubs and I'm
watching joey go onstage and crush them,
telling me he's not funny.
I'm like,
you're out of your mind.
Yeah,
you're just wrong.
I've seen it.
Not only that,
I'm a fan of comedy.
I'm not just.
I'm not just a fan of things that are
gross.
I'm a fan.
In fact,
if someone's gross and it's not well
done,
it's appalling to me.
I didn't want to.
Yeah,
I know when people are just being gross
for the sake of trying to get a
reaction.
It's annoying.
It's like it's bad on your brain.
Especially when you hear it more than
once.
It's like it's.
It's,
it's,
it's grading.
Joe Not doing that.
He just,
he's being himself and I was watching
him kill over and over and over again
and having these people telling me that
it's not good.
And then podcast came along,
you know,
seven,
eight years ago and got to know him and
then now when we have them on,
it's like always one of our shows and
admitted always
so,
uh,
out.
And I was telling you before the podcast
too,
and I'll tell joe if he's watching.
Joey,
don't,
you don't need guests on your podcast.
I really like it when it's just joey and
Lee and they just talk.
I liked that too,
but I like Joey with guests too.
I just like Joey,
I'm going to direct and produce Joey
standup special.
Oh that's great.
We couldn't get anybody to do it.
It's just like they still don't get it.
Like there's a lot of people that still
don't get it and I'm hoping they get it
when we put something together,
but we're going to film something that
the Ice House and I'm gonna put it all
together.
Yeah.
And I'm going to direct it and produce
it and the whole thing.
And just have someone edit it and just
put it together and just make the
ultimate Joey Diaz comedy specials so
people could know and um,
we're going to do a shit load of shows
too,
because that's the other thing,
like when a comic has to do one show
ready here,
kyle,
this is your one moment to be funny and
it's going to be seeing forever.
It's like you smoking pot and realizing
millions of people.
Exactly that,
that's a,
that's sort of what it's like for a
comic to do a special.
So you do one,
you get it into can you feel loose?
Then you get that second one and you're
like,
oh,
we got it.
And then the third one you're like,
now we really got it needed a fourth
one.
The fourth one is generally like a real
comedy show.
Like where there's no,
no concern,
no worries,
no issues.
Well,
the evolution of stuff is interesting
because it's almost impossible to start
something and just get it like you.
It requires a lot of time,
a lot of effort,
a lot of cultivation,
a lot of attention.
And you know,
it's,
it's that book,
I forget who wrote it,
but the idea of you have to do something
for 10,000 hours or whatever the fuck it
is that gladwell no.
So they might be,
that might be a Malcolm Gladwell,
but that's true.
And you know what I,
what I say is even if,
let's say you don't get there with
whatever you're trying to do,
you're definitely gonna be better after
those 10,000 hours.
And also you might learn a lot about
yourself and a lot about what you're
capable of and a lot about dedication
and discipline.
If you just stick with something.
And I've always said,
you know,
people like to shit on one dimensional
people and act like,
ah,
you know,
you're not supposed to do I suppose to
be well rounded and this and that.
But you know,
again,
to bring up tiger woods,
how the fuck do you think he got good at
golf?
You know,
how he got good at golf by only fucking
playing golf.
And he was able to find something that
he got so fucking good at it and create
meaning in his life.
And also use that to develop different
parts of your personality.
And it's,
I'm in favor of people doing whatever
they think
suits their creative pursuits.
Don't,
don't feel bad if you're somebody who's
all I.
all I do is this one fucking thing.
Okay,
well you can get really fucking good at
it.
And who,
even if it's some shit like playing
video games,
okay,
go be the fucking best video game player
in the world.
Might as well if that's what you're
really good at and you can do the time
and put in the work,
especially if you enjoy that.
And there's something about getting the
GRC.
Jiro dreams of Sushi.
No,
really interesting documentary.
One of the weirdest things about it,
it's just a,
there's a term that the Japanese use for
someone who does something over and over
and over again,
even a simple task and becomes a master
at it.
Do you remember what that term was?
Jamey.
Remember that?
Um,
but this is one guy in the film I was at
first I was very skeptical.
Like,
I'm not watching a fucking movie about a
due to make Sushi because the fish,
he puts it on the right,
but then when you see what really goes
into it to show Coonan I think,
how'd he say it?
Show coon and um,
and that is,
what is the definition of that was the,
what is it?
What do they call it?
What is the actual.
A tradesman?
No,
it was like someone who practices
something methodically,
meticulously forever until they get it.
And this guy was just making an egg
dish.
It's like really fluffy egg dish and he,
you know,
how you get those,
you get Sushi sometimes it has that
little piece of egg on it.
Like this.
I don't eat Sushi,
tastes.
We don't eat pussy either.
Well this fucking camera off as kind of
the you want to deal with the Sushi.
I'm not dealing with
the um.
Anyway,
this guy was like almost in tears
because he finally reached this state
where the guy was like,
yeah,
this is the way to make the egg dish the
mastery of one's profession show she'll
and things I'm seeing for definition.
Okay,
show coon and mastery of one's
profession,
but in that this is this thing that this
guy had been studying the art of making
Sushi,
like the properly aging of the fish,
which I didn't even know.
I thought the fish was fresh.
I thought that was the move was aging.
They know they want to.
They own refrigerators for long periods
of time that I would've never guessed
that they did that with fish.
Obviously with meet everybody knows
about dry aged meat.
You're.
You're literally letting the bacteria
break down the meat over long periods of
time,
but what's interesting is you would
never guess that there are so many
different angles to doing something as
simple as making that dish so much that
goes into it and if you care enough to
look at all the nuances of it and to
really get into the specifics of it,
then you can create something that has
meaning to you and really can develop
you as a person.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's something in that where you.
You're.
You're exploring your own potential for
getting good at things,
right?
That's what you're doing.
You're exploring like what?
What's keeping this guy from making this
perfect egg dish and how does he nail
it?
Is it a timing issue?
Is it A.
I mean,
is he getting the ingredients correct?
I don't know what's what ingredients are
in this egg dish,
but I don't know why I'm even using
that,
but for anything,
there's some exploration of these ideas.
What is this?
Kaizen is someone that's the word that's
the word.
Continuous improvement,
a longterm approach to work that
systematically seeks to achieve small
incremental changes in processes in
order to improve efficiency and quality
Kaizen,
but I think it was show Coonan the show
couldn't definition and said like the
definition of tradesmen isn't good
enough,
but there's more deeper meaning when you
get into like the Japanese cultural
expert.
Okay.
So either one of those folks.
Yeah.
I actually think that this topic that
we're talking about right now,
this is one of the main reasons why
Jordan Peterson got very popular is
because Jordan Peterson,
he talks a lot about stuff that other
people take for granted about self
improvement and like getting your own
shit together.
Right?
And so that was like a market that was
awaiting to be served for so long where
people wanted to have a little bit of
direction and structure and framework as
to how do I go about doing that.
And then this guy comes along and he's
very well spoken and he can kind of
break that down for people.
Yeah.
And also he,
he exemplifies a lot of those traits we
were just discussing when he was talking
about his first book.
And I'm one of the things that he said
is that it took him 15 years to write
the book.
The 12 rules book.
No,
the first,
the first book was on the Cold War and
he was talking about how he went over
every sentence to see if it can be
improved or criticized.
But do you do that with your podcasts?
Do you listen back or now because
there's sometimes.
Sometimes if especially if I fucked up,
I fucked up,
I'll listen.
Or if I said something I know that could
be a bit,
said something.
Well,
I'll have to go back and get another one
of.
They're trying it.
Yeah,
I'll do that.
Or you know,
if some people say something that's
really intense,
like the David Goggins podcast,
I plan on listening to that one again
because it was so inspirational.
Oh yeah.
I turned it on.
These guys talking about how he ran a
374,000 miles and meanwhile I'm like,
great,
I'll be on Joe show next week talking
about chronic masturbation.
He's um,
I mean he's intense,
intense.
It's not a good enough word.
It's like we need to.
Yeah.
So Coonan word for intensity.
He's um,
but also you could get a lot out of
that.
There's something about inspiration in
that form,
like the exemplified form.
There's a term that a,
the Koreans used for a taekwondo
instructor.
It's a Sabal Nim and it means one who
leads by example and that there's,
there's something about a guy like that,
that,
that really does practice what he
preaches,
and,
and is so motivational just by his own
actions.
When you hear him talk about it and you
know,
he's actually done it.
Like,
you just want to like,
why am I sitting down?
I got to go.
You just want to.
I think you said that after the.
That's right,
you were like,
I'm in the gym,
but fuck,
I just want to go do something.
It's just,
there's something about guys like him
that are very,
very valuable to us and I think people
get real cynical about the idea of
inspiration because there's so many
ridiculous like not to single out girls
because there's guys do it too,
but it's,
there's some funny shit about girls just
stick their butt out on instagram and
they have all these motivational quotes
accord and I were talking about it
before.
It's amazing how many Kim Kardashians
clones exist now.
I mean,
and even in her own family,
I don't know all the names of them,
but one of the younger ones,
she,
it's like she went to the plastic
surgeon and she was like,
I want to look like Kim.
Yeah.
And they just give her the same face.
You know,
what the fuck is up with that?
The but thing is the most disgusting
thing where they're taking fat and stuff
and an into their ass and they developed
this diaper.
But I mean,
there's a lot of people out there with
diaper,
but I met a girl the other day that had
but she was at the comedy store and I
couldn't look away.
I was like,
what is happening to her?
But because I knew it wasn't real.
I knew she had.
Okay,
so these spindly legs.
Yeah,
the skinny legs.
And then the.
Well,
if a girl has a big like hips and the
right member art chrome comics,
do you remember our chrome comics now?
Our KARMAS are crumb.
There was a great documentary called
crumb and it's about this guy who's this
really eccentric perverted cartoonist
from the 19 seventies.
And he would always draw these women
with these enormous legs and enormous
but,
but they weren't fat.
They were just as voluptuous.
They will know.
It was a path voluptuous into like super
athlete DNA.
Like if you could get that girl makes a
male babies with it,
you would have a fucking ultimate
warrior like that.
See that woman.
Like they're perfect.
Yeah.
How to have fun with a strong girl.
And you see our chrome.
That's actually him.
Ronnie Coleman legs.
Yeah,
that's actually him with his boner
because he was just a really frail,
Dorky guy and he's got this image of
this woman who just looks like a tank.
She has these giant muscle legs and and
big boobs,
but not like ridiculous stripper boobs,
but more like just Super Alpha Dna.
Female boobs.
Yeah.
He was a freaky guy.
Like,
look at him.
He's got soccer.
I mean that's,
that's who he was like really the one
above that.
Jamie.
The one to the right.
Yeah.
Right.
They're like,
oh my goodness is what he used to draw.
He was always drawing this enormous,
powerful women.
This guy was definitely into getting
dominated.
Oh yeah.
He would just shove his whole head in
their pussy or so I'm sure,
like,
look at him.
He hit him riding one.
I guess he's supposed to be having sex
with him and this guy definitely noted
in like two seconds.
Yeah.
Oh man,
look,
he's choking them in these carts.
Like he's always choking them.
Like you literally couldn't have an art
crumb today that looks like it looks
kind of like a woody allen to.
Yeah.
Well,
see if you could find a video of him,
our crum,
the documentaries.
Fascinating because I think he wound up
moving to France or something like that.
I think you want to leaving America.
Um,
but there's,
there's actually,
if you go to video you'll,
you'll find there's video of him.
But that was the guy.
He's a really fascinating guy that's on
him.
It looks just like I'm on the right
not on the right.
Oh,
that's not definitely not the right guy
on the left.
Does that him?
Oh,
there it is.
Oh yeah,
he just looks odd.
It was just holding up that picture.
Maybe it's also because I'm looking at
him now as an older man.
Um,
the lot of the video that I'd seen was
him.
It bothers me to look at him and think
like,
that guy has a strong sex drive.
Like,
oh,
that's it.
Yeah.
You might not.
He might just save it up for every
couple of weeks and they try one of
those cartoons and beat off to it or
find a cow suitable.
Exactly.
Pay Somebody to sit on his face.
A strange,
strange character though.
It doesn't matter.
Jamie.
Sorry.
What's that?
I say it looks he did Fritz the cat too.
Yeah,
you did.
Fritz.
The cat.
He did a lot of a pretty famous,
uh,
animated or cartoon comic book Type
Things,
but they were all at cartoonish
features.
Everybody was weird.
Yeah.
And you think Kim has now made that
that's the standard and see this is like
a real like that,
those women's asses that are chrome
drew.
I'm not justifying his stuff,
but they were freak ge DNA specimen.
Sure.
Those women at giant thighs and giant
ass is.
And that's who they were.
Whereas with Kim,
she's got those spindly,
not,
yeah,
like her,
but is this,
did just,
it's a surgical creation.
Like there's pictures of her that are
online that make it look good,
but they're all photoshop and we found
out about that because she got Paparazzi
Razzi when she was in Mexico.
They caught her on the beach.
That was the one that they were showing
way gets worse than that way.
Grocer.
They caught her wandering around the
beach and they took photos of her,
like real Paparazzi photos.
She would have fake Paparazzi photos
where she would hire pop routes,
take photos of her,
and then she would photoshop a mop and
they made it look like everything was in
place.
But it's not.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a disaster.
This is what it really looks like.
Yeah.
So is that it?
Okay.
So if the legs matched the ass,
I'd,
I'd be totally fine with that.
But even that acid is a distortion
because there's so much going on there
because you,
you're not supposed to have that much
fat in one place.
It a girl has an ass like that has legs
to match it.
That's what I'm saying.
If the legs match the ass,
I'd like it.
But the legs.
Yeah.
The throw it off his little
little twig,
legs and then you got the message.
It's like those guys that shoot synthol
until
it's the same thing,
like you're not,
that's not a real ass.
Like I just like those synthol muscles
are not real monster there.
So obviously fake.
But yeah,
because of the legs though,
but the legs were matched it.
I'd be like,
that's nice.
But it wouldn't match it.
It's just not possible.
I've seen some where it matches.
Yeah.
But not like that.
Just it's the whole thing is a disaster.
It says.
Have you ever watched the show?
Forgot,
look at his face.
He's like,
I'm mailing this shit.
Yeah,
look at this.
I got this shit on lock.
He's got tits.
He does.
I mean,
these guys wind up getting horrible
infections too.
Sometimes they've,
they.
Well they gangrene and shit.
They say that there's an actual thing.
Oh my God.
You say you see,
they say how there's an actual thing
called bigorexia.
Like there's Anorexia and there's bigger
x body dysmorphia exists with A.
I mean there's,
there's people that have body dysmorphia
in terms of their facial features.
They just can't stop tweaking their
nose.
Did you hear about,
um,
I read an article about how somebody was
like,
I know I'm supposed to have a hand here,
but it feels so fucking foreign that.
And there's been multiple recorded cases
of this where they will shove their
fucking hand and dry ice so that they
can get an amputated said afterwards,
they can say,
look,
I'm free.
I finally feel normal.
It's like you just.
And they save it to them.
It feels like if I had a fucking third
hand just growing out of here,
I'd feel like that shit doesn't belong.
There are some people where they feel
like their hand doesn't fucking belong
and what that shows is like the
variation in human psychology is so
fucking broad that it's scary because
when you really digest that,
that exists,
you also can understand how well there's
monsters out there to want to fucking
massacre people and they dream about
that shit and that's how they get their
rocks off.
Yeah.
Human.
The human mind vary so much.
There's so many different paths that
thoughts can go down and there's so many
different weird pathologies that that
the mind is capable of,
but the idea that you would think that
you're supposed to be handicapped,
not handicapped,
and so you want to chop off a foot or
something like that.
It's really,
I mean it's not common,
I,
we shouldn't say it's common,
but it's,
it's,
it's definitely documented.
So let me ask you,
what's your take on,
um,
if somebody is transgender and they want
the surgery and let's say they're either
in the military or they're in prison or
something like that,
is that something that you think should
be provided for them or no?
Um hmm.
That's a good question.
I haven't really thought about too much.
I don't think so.
I don't think that that's an elective
surgery and people would say no,
it's not elective surgery.
But you think that other people should
pay for that?
Boy,
I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
I don't have it.
Okay.
So if I was gonna say I know why people
are transgender there.
Transgender because of body dysmorphia.
They're transgender because of gender
dysmorphia there.
They're transgender because of this.
Because of that,
because of abuse,
because of
easily susceptible to suggestion.
I would just be talking about in my ass.
I don't really know.
I would imagine though there was a broad
spectrum of reasons why someone becomes
transgender.
Some of them being that they literally
have the wrong programming in their
brain.
Some of them being that they.
I mean they could have thought that they
were fucking Wood Elf.
I mean,
or the.
That's the furry shit is the weird shit.
Oh that's weird.
But very shit too is like I've talked to
some furries.
I'm sorry,
I'm thinking other kids,
that's the shit I'm thinking of.
The other
can shit is nuts,
but there's also people that identify
with being a six year old girl.
I mean there's been cases where people
identify as being much younger than they
are and they think they should be able
to have sex with young kids.
So I feel like.
So on the transgender one,
I feel like for a very long time,
I don't think I understood it at all.
And then I think I finally got it when
it was explained to me like,
okay,
imagine that you as a straight,
you know,
CIS gender male,
if I use that term,
whatever it is,
don't do it.
As a child.
Let's say I walk outside and I'm forced
every time I go outside to wear a
fucking wig and lipstick and high heels
and a fucking dress and I'd be mortified
because I,
this is not who the fuck I am and why am
I wearing this shit?
Right?
So if you think the first point you
made,
which is,
hey,
maybe they were just born with the wrong
programming that they're born
biologically male,
but they're really feel like they're a
woman or vice versa.
So if that's the case and it's basically
like torture for them to not be the
other thing,
well then I kind of understand that and
I'm in favor of them being able to get
that surgery where they lose me,
not transgender people,
but when I get lost in this whole
conversation is like the gender fluidity
one,
like I was a male,
now I'm a woman and now I'm a man again.
And then a woman again and then I'm a
man again.
Just fucking idiot.
He's,
it's like you have a person at a certain
point,
there are things that are real and there
are things that are not real.
And I feel like it delegitimizes the
ones that are real when you go to goofy
and too far and you try to pretend like
gender fluidity is a thing.
Well,
isn't it what we're talking about
earlier when we were talking about left
wing
people versus right wing people that you
in in the term left wing people,
anybody can join and you're going to get
people like the green haired people that
were disrupting heather hiring speech
because she was saying there's a
difference between men and women.
You're going to get those nutty fuckers
and then you're going to get people that
are just reasonable people that happened
to be progressive.
You're going to get that with gender
fluidity.
You're going to get that with people
that are transgender.
that are,
you know,
it just going to get a wide variety.
It's very difficult to nail things down,
decide,
but for like for everybody who looks at
that and then gets turned off to that
and says,
you know what?
I align with the right wing because of
that culture stuff.
Like,
I get that feeling over the culture
issues,
but again,
the point that I would make to them is
just don't forget that when I talk about
politics and when I talk about where I
fall on the political spectrum,
to me,
I break it down toward the,
on policy and where I fall on the policy
issues and what we should implement,
uh,
in order to fix the country.
And on those issues like we were talking
about earlier,
I'm pretty reliably left wing and the
polls show that the American people
actually lean in that direction.
So if you focus on those issues,
the economic issues,
the substantive issues that change
people's lives,
then,
um,
you know,
I think that one can look at the culture
issues as almost like a diversion
because it really is a gateway to other
ideas that I think are terrible.
So I think the idea of people on the
left calling out that goofiness is a
good thing that you can redirect them
and be like,
well,
this is what I actually stand for.
This is what people who are on the left
and want to improve people's lives
really want to fight for.
Yeah.
I was talking to Douglas Murray about
this yesterday and there's just this
thing where everyone was forced to say
that Caitlyn Jenner is beautiful.
Like you couldn't just accept that she
was a woman.
You were forced to say that she was
beautiful and that she is
hero and that's where you get the
gateway to the right because people go,
if you're going to get,
that's what you're going to tell me
represents the left.
Then go fuck yourself because you're
just not being.
You're not telling the truth.
Yeah,
you're not so and it's.
I don't,
I hate the thing where it's like we have
to care more about feelings.
Didn't what's accurate,
right?
So I don't know why there needs to be a
giant wave on the left of the take.
No bullshit approach to stuff.
Why
comes to the transgender thing too?
They're there.
You need to be open to all avenues of
this discussion and one thing that I
think we need to be open to,
we need to think very carefully about
why it is that someone needs surgery to
be themselves.
Why it is that someone needs exogenous
hormones that,
that aren't native to their biology to
be themselves like someone who wants to
take estrogen is born a male.
Someone if you feel that you're a woman
or you feel that you're in the wrong
body,
does it make sense that nature wants you
to get surgery?
Does it make sense that nature wants you
to take hormones that don't exist in
your body?
I mean,
is this as.
This is a rational area of contention
and discussion.
This is something that people should
talk about.
Like when you say if someone is forced
to wear lipstick and high heels and make
up and walking down the street,
but that's not who you are.
Wouldn't that frustrate you?
Yes,
it would,
but it doesn't necessarily conversely
work where you are walking down the
street without lipstick and high heels
and makeup and you saying that's what
I'm supposed to have.
Well,
no,
because that's not real like lipstick.
As something you choose to apply high
heels or something you choose to wear,
it's no one's forcing you to not have
those things on.
So you saying that those things are what
you really are.
Well,
no,
you're adding those things to you.
What you really are,
as you know,
makeup naked,
wake up in the morning,
take off your clothes.
That's where the fuck you really are.
If you say that you should have the
right to wear makeup and the right to
wear that.
Of course she had the right,
so get your face tattooed like a mowery
should have the right to do whatever the
fuck you want,
but that that's who you really are,
that that's somehow your true self.
There might be an underlying
psychological issue there that's
relevant and to discuss that puts you in
this category of being transphobic or
insensitive or or right wing.
I don't think that's accurate or fair
because I think this is a real weird
issue.
It's very weird and I think the only
people that truly understand it are the
people that are going through it
themselves,
the people that actually haven't and you
know,
we can call upon those people to explain
it to us,
but the,
you get a broad spectrum of answers from
those people as well.
What if,
um,
so what if it is kind of like depression
in a way?
So if some,
if you give chemical assistance,
is somebody who's going through
depression,
everybody goes bright good because you
want that person to feel like they're
happy and all necessarily even think
that that's good.
I think exhaust all other possibilities
first including exercise and diet and
that's sure,
sure.
But there,
but there are examples of people who do
have that genuine chemical imbalance.
They do,
but why do they have that genuine
chemical imbalance?
Johann Hari on the podcast,
who's.
I saw that.
Yeah,
and he makes a lot of really good points
about like what is it that's happening
in your life with?
Is it your,
your,
your situation with your relationship,
your career,
your life,
your health,
all these different things need to be
taken into consideration instead of just
putting some duck tape over it in the
term of these SSRI and all these
different psych medications,
if they're handing out just as easy as
they're handing out oxycontin's,
they're passing these fucking things
around here.
Only overlap for sure.
Radically affect your consciousness.
So let's say everybody has all their
ducks in a row and they're exercising,
they're eating healthy,
they're doing everything by the book.
And uh,
if you look at it on paper,
you're supposed to go,
yes,
that person should be healthy.
And what's,
ah,
what the fuck's her name?
Oh,
Cara,
Santa Maria,
who you've had on the podcast before.
And she talks about how,
listen,
I was depressed and they tried a whole
bunch of different antidepressants.
They finally got me on one that worked.
And then she says like,
listen,
I want people to understand.
You need to look at this like treatment.
Look at it like,
you know,
hey,
I've got a fucking disease and they got
to give me antibiotics in order to feel
better.
The problem with us as real scientists
and doctors to disagree with that and I
don't know if she exhausted every other
possibility and Kara,
she worships at the throne of science
and she thinks that this is the way to
handle it and she might be right.
It also might be possible that if she
had rigorous exercise on a daily basis,
cleaned up her diet and did a bunch of
other things that maybe that would be
just as effective if not more.
I don't know.
So I don't know.
I don't know what she's done,
but I that automatically assuming that
this,
this blanket statement called
depression,
which could be.
What does that even mean?
You're not happy with your station in
life.
What does that mean?
You're not happy with your body?
I don't know what it means.
I mean,
will you tell me that you have it.
You know what it is when you have it,
but how do you know that what you have
is the same as what that guy has with
what she has or what other great sure we
don't know,
but we do know is the human body reacts
in very different ways.
When it's well fed with nutrients and
when you exercise on a daily basis,
you flood your body with a natural
endorphins that come from that exercise.
When you surround yourself with a loving
community,
when you engage in things that are
rewarding to you,
all these things have a very positive
effect on the way your mind works as
well as the way your body feels.
That way your body feels has a positive
result on the way your mind works.
To think of either one of being
independent of each other.
I think it's ignorant.
It's the same thing.
She has the same and there's radical.
I'm not a depressed person,
but I feel way better after I exercise.
Of course.
I mean there's science on that that says
when you exercise,
you eat right.
Of course you're going to get at.
Definitely get a boost in your mood,
but it's hard to do and that's why
people like to take a pill and that's
totally true.
And he also liked to justify their
actions when people take a pill and that
pill is effective and they go,
well,
this is my thing,
this is what did it for me.
They're like,
okay,
but at what cost?
So can you orgasm anymore?
Like there's a lot of shit that happens
to people that when they take those
fucking things it really fuck them up.
Sure.
So if you're making the point that
they're overprescribed and people rely
on them too much and it's part of the
culture in a negative way,
totally agree with you.
Yes.
If,
if we look at the example of say
paranoid schizophrenia where it's
somebody who literally see shit that's
not there and it's a genuine
psychological disorder where they needed
very powerful drug like seroquel or
something like that.
So in the case of transgenderism,
what if it's more analogous to a mental
state that's as real as that,
where the,
you know what I mean?
Like a business solution,
surgery,
sexual reassignment surgery.
And how do we even know,
I don't know,
but then this gets back to the point you
made about the personal freedom angle of
it where they say,
you know what,
I'm going to do this and this is what I
want to do.
I definitely think they should have
personal freedom to do it.
Just like they think they should have
personal freedom to get their fucking
nose pierced and do whatever you want to
do.
But should you have to pay for it?
Well that's.
Then that gets into the broader
conversation about who should pay for
medical coverage period,
but is this,
is this an elective thing?
Like how about girls that identify with
a girl who has big tits identified as
big tits and I have a little tits and so
you're saying the line is fucking
blurry.
Well it's.
It's certainly the same thing.
It's the same thing in terms of you
don't like your physical state and you
want someone to change it.
And if you say you would be happy if you
had d cups,
but you have a cups and you're convinced
this is the key to our happiness.
How is that any different than a person
and you could get mad at me all you
want,
but you were talking about the physical
state.
Sure.
To physical state of someone like how,
how can you,
how can you say that the only way to fix
this or how could you offer that up as a
possible avenue that these people that
can pursue it.
If,
if you,
if there's any surgery that can help you
and you want other people to pay for
that surgery,
I don't care.
Just because it's it pertains to gender
doesn't mean we have to automatically
act.
We ask.
I don't think that's.
I don't think that's rational and it
when it comes to breasts or other other
various elective surgeries,
I strongly feel that people should pay
for those themselves.
Sure.
I will.
Absolutely.
When it comes to the example you give
about breasts,
but I totally agree 100 percent.
Why is that different than sex change?
I'm not saying it is.
I'm not saying it is either.
I'm just saying,
um,
if that is the case where,
and by the way,
I haven't read the science on this,
but I'm sure there has been silence on
this and they've answered the question
as to whether or not doing that surgery
is effective.
What's not?
Here's the problem.
There's a massive massive suicide rate.
It's over 40 percent.
So even even post operation.
And I was going to say,
am I wrong in my assumption that pre
operation death,
when more the suicides are versus
postop,
I don't think it changes.
Pretty show.
See if,
let's,
let's be accurate about this.
Um,
suicide rates,
pre post transgender sexual reassignment
operations.
I am pretty sure that it's very similar
that it doesn't change.
And then there's also causation versus
correlation,
right?
Is it because they were depressed
because they were in the wrong body that
lead them down this road and now here
they are and they just can't get past
it.
Even if they have the surgery,
there's still bummed out.
They're not accepted by society as a
woman,
even if a become a trans woman,
they're still not accepted by society.
And could that be changed by us being
more open minded and loving and nature?
Is it nurture?
Is it the environment?
Is it in the person?
I don't know what.
I don't either.
But if it is legitimate mental health
disorder,
which appears to be called,
it used to be called gender dysphoria.
And now if you used the term gender
dysphoria,
it's hate speech.
Like it turns the bus.
Talking about this might get this
podcast demonetized.
I'm sure it will be.
Probably will be.
If it is gender dysphoria then wouldn't
it actually be a medical condition where
the treatment should be paid for?
It's a good question.
Is that the correct treatment for gender
dysphoria?
Is that the correct treatment for
someone who thinks that they should have
no hand?
Should you chop that handoff?
What do you think?
I don't know.
She you chop a penis off.
That's what Caitlyn Jenner did it.
Wait,
did you get did eventually?
But the muscle area statement after she
did that,
she said that she is no more of a woman
now that she was before.
Well then,
Hey,
definitely keep your dick.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
If you were still a woman before and
pretty much everybody except now,
which is why I did this really radical
thing like no.
Well you did admit that you did that for
a reason,
that you really wanted to do it and now
it's different.
I mean,
I dunno,
maybe street creds letter her to have
the operation to fully get.
I mean she's fully accepted by that
community and become a spokesperson,
but the way,
and it's funny because she's,
she's super right wing on other issues.
Remember when she went on she was like,
I'm a very traditional,
a traditional.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
So a lot of people in the Trans
community where like,
you know what?
Fuck her.
Because she was out there arguing,
I forget it was gay marriage marriage,
but then there was another one where
she's talking about economics and she
was,
you know,
like pull yourself up by your
bootstraps.
It's like fucking privileged prick
without.
How much money do you have for just
sitting around all day and getting paid
from the Kardashians?
She's a mail card dash in the show is
was Swiss shows.
What she's on that fucking frivolous,
ridiculous show and she became a really
bizarre side note and pop culture and
that's what's going on.
I mean,
when you listen to her talk,
she's like one of the worst spokespeople
ever for the Trans Community and a lot
of trans people say that they're like,
we don't want her as.
Because they're,
you know,
if you trans people are individually.
So you left a look at people like
they're individuals and when they,
when somebody put out as this is a
leader of this movement.
And then it's like,
well that makes her examples.
The one,
the woman who created Sirius satellite
radio,
she also created a satellite navigation
system.
She used to be a man,
in fact,
very,
very brilliant person.
I interviewed her for Phi,
for that Joe Rogan questions,
everything show.
She created a model of her wife who they
actually had babies together and then
she became a woman and uh,
they stayed together and she could,
she created a robot of her,
her wife,
and she's like constantly programming it
and changing it and adding new language
and new vocabulary to it.
And she thinks eventually as technology
improves,
she's going to be able to recreate her
wife and a robot.
By the way,
another great example,
Brianna Westbrook,
what does this say?
They're uncomfortable truth that many
surveys,
including the 2011 Swedish study,
indicate that suicide rates remain high
after sex reassignment surgery.
The Swedish study reports that people
have had sex reassignment surgery are 19
times more likely to die by suicide then
as the general population.
To be fair,
to be fair,
I see the sources life site news,
which is a very,
very right wing.
That's true.
But the national center for transgender
equality reported in 2014 that 40
percent of the people who identify as
transgender have attempted suicide.
Very well may be true.
I'm just saying that's the national
center for transgender equality or just
breaking up this article here,
which is the study halo as one is legit.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's legit.
So,
um,
but they're,
they're reporting facts from studies.
And,
uh,
I mean this is,
this is pretty well established that
there's a high suicide rate amongst
transgender people pre and post
reassignment surgery for the,
the,
we go back to the same thing.
It doesn't necessarily mean that they
couldn't be happy if they weren't just
fully accepted by society.
I mean,
I don't know if it's,
I think Caitlyn Jenner's probably
happier because she gets a shitload of
attention now.
She was in the shadow behind while I'm
over here,
I'm over here,
by the way,
now she's the,
you know,
front and center.
Fucking vogue magazine.
Yeah.
A lot of attention.
Speaking of a people who would be a
better example and,
and a better,
you know,
face of the transgender movement.
Uh,
Brianna Westbrook is a candidate who's
running for office and there's actually
a special election today and she's
running for Congress and she's really
inspirational.
Uh,
I,
I know about her because I found a
Justice Democrats,
which was a
group that it was going to primary
corporate democrats and run candidates
who take no corporate pac money and
she's one of the candidates.
And what you find is it the people who
are really respectful are the people who
they like,
she happens to be transgender,
but she's not putting that front and
center.
You know what I'm saying?
Like a person,
she's a person.
Exactly.
And she's going,
here are the things I believe in and I
think this will improve everybody's
lives and I'm gonna run on these issues
and it's not like,
Hey,
I'm transgender and if you don't vote
for me then you're a bigot.
Right,
right,
right.
That's,
that's a very good point.
And I think open mindedness is
incredibly
cool in our wide diverse society and
when people,
when people push back against that,
it creates all sorts of giant problems
and I just think it doesn't matter.
You should be able to do whatever you
want to do and if it doesn't affect you,
what do you care?
I think we should
be really,
really,
really careful.
But what we do to children though,
and there's a nice.
I saw your conversation on that recently
and I think you made a bunch of good
points.
Like when is it okay to say,
you know what?
Okay,
if you want to do the surgery now you
can do the surgery.
Well,
there's a,
there's a
going back to heather hiring and Eric
Weinstein.
There was a,
um,
an article that I believe Eric,
not Eric,
I'm sorry,
Bret,
Bret Weinstein put up on his twitter
yesterday,
or maybe it was heather,
what they were discussing,
um,
this,
this real problem with kids who are
really young where it becomes a trendy
thing to,
to think that they're in the wrong
gender and then they get reinforcement
from their very progressive friends who
also get excited about this idea and
then to intervene surgically or
chemically when your body is still in
development.
You're 13 or whatever the fuck you are.
You don't know what you are yet and you
should be able to give yourself a chance
to grow and develop.
But there's a lot of people that
disagree,
including people that are already
transgender.
That in my mind they're probably more
supportive of it because they want more
people to do it.
Like Steven crowder had this weird thing
where he and jared,
that guy that he does his show with,
went to this meeting and they were
talking about they just does undercover
film thing where they're talking about
their six year old,
like,
is that too young to transition them?
And they're like,
no.
Matter of fact studies show that it.
That's the good,
it's a good time to do it and that you
could transition back if he changes his
mind.
And he was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
No,
you can't.
He using hormone blockers in a kid,
you're going to radically affect the way
that kid develops as a grown adult.
Yeah.
I don't know what line is the proper
line?
Adulthood.
Is it 16?
18,
a 21.
I think it's probably 25.
I think a fully developed frontal
cortex.
The only problem I have with that is
like I want.
I hate the fact that we have all of
these different lines in society.
Like,
okay,
you have to be this age to drink after
me this age to do Tibet.
You get tobacco.
You have to be this age for porn.
I think a lot of those lines are
incorrect and I think science will show
that the frontal lobe is not fully
developed until you're 25 years old,
so.
But should you also not be able to vote
until really?
Yes.
Yeah,
I think I agree with that.
Why?
Because I screen haired fuckers that
were in his speech,
they were all like 19 and goofy.
They're gonna look back at that video
someday and go,
what the fuck was wrong with that list?
And there's a lot of kids,
they're growing their own vegetables and
they have to work for a living.
But that's the thing is that those
people are assholes too.
And also not that smart.
Some of them,
some of them of course,
but then so we were just young,
you know,
in my mind,
I think we should just draw a clean line
at 16 for everything.
Oh God.
You can fight for your country.
What do you want to have?
Kylie Jenner is a fucking president
because I don't see a lot of them.
I don't want a baby kids.
I want to make it sort of baby them
either,
but I don't think like really radical
choices should be up to them when their
brain's not fully developed,
but at the same time you're so you're so
young,
you don't think.
When did you first.
When did you first drink?
It was definitely before I was 21 at a
party.
I was in high school.
I don't know.
Somewhere around there.
Somewhere in your teens?
Yeah.
So then should you be locked up for
that?
No,
not locked up,
but I shouldn't be.
It shouldn't be legal.
Shouldn't be able to go into a liquor
store and buy a pint of Jack Daniels in
Europe.
I don't think they have any age laws in
Europe for alcohol and stuff.
Right.
Well,
am I wrong about that?
I think there is.
I think it's.
Yeah,
I think it's fairly young that maybe
wine and things along with that.
I think first of all,
having things that are forbidden
definitely accentuates the desire to
have them.
We know that.
Sure.
Telling a kid that cigarettes are bad.
You can't have cigarettes.
They want to smoke cigarettes.
They want to be rebels,
they want to drink,
they want to,
they want to do things that the adults
do.
And what age for sexual consent.
I mean this is,
we obviously can't.
You're 25 for that,
right?
So you have to draw a reasonable line
where you say,
okay,
enough people have developed to the
point where they're physically mature,
but there's a big difference between
sex,
which I don't think is a bad thing.
I think.
I don't think it's a disastrous thing.
I don't mind the different lines,
like 21,
$60 to have sex with each other when
they like it.
Like I think kids should be able to give
you some of the massage as a 17 year old
boy and a 17 year old girl of course
that should be able to make out and they
should be able to fuck up.
Do you think it's our job to responsibly
educate them about birth control and
about consent and about.
And it also,
you know,
there's different styles of parenting.
You know,
some people grow up in horrible
households where the dad's massage and
there's no mom and you know,
this kid's going to have a fucked up
idea.
What women are same could be said about
women or girls who grow up with a
hateful mother who hates men.
I mean you have a lot of weird shit that
you have to get over as you become an
adult.
As you move out of the nest and you
become your own person,
established your own ideas based on your
life experiences and education,
what you've learned from all the other
people that you've interacted with.
I mean,
it's not a hard fast rule,
but I think there's a big difference
between that and voting on what happens
with our future.
What happens with war,
what happens with.
There's so many things that a 16 year
old kids is now ready for.
So.
But like again,
my.
I think my counter argument to that is,
but there are a lot of fucking 68 year
old idiots out there too and we don't
try to deal with itemize
their vote because I think we should.
But anytime you have a system where you
say,
ah,
well you're an idiot so you can't vote,
it's always inevitably just flip back to
be used against the,
the poor in society.
So that.
So.
Well look,
I mean there's a great quote from
Winston Churchill.
I think you said democracy is the worst
form of government except for all
others.
Yeah.
That's great.
Cool.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that's.
So that's kind of what we're talking
about here.
And in terms of drawing the line,
I don't know,
I just feel like there's something right
about drawing one line and saying
everything over this.
But I do hear you like it is true that
sex is a very different thing from
voting.
So yeah,
I don't think we should regulate sex
except for adults having sex with
minors.
I agree a hundred percent.
When I was 17,
my girlfriend was 16 and I remember I
turned 18 and she turned 17.
And there was a year.
You were a criminal?
Yeah.
Someone told me that if we kept having
sex,
that I would go to jail.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Are you serious?
This is madness.
Yes,
I mean we've been banging it out for 11
months now.
If we could stop now.
It makes no sense.
Yeah.
I was really nervous.
I was like,
what if I go to jail?
I don't think that works that way.
I don't think they put you in jail for
that.
But yeah,
I remember how bad I felt when I was in
high school and I was smoking weed and I
felt like if I get caught doing this
shit,
but then you think about it and it's
like,
hold the fuck on Bill Clinton.
US.
No,
but I didn't know.
And Barack Obama was part of the fucking
tomb gang or some shit where he would,
what?
He was part of this thing called the
tomb gang where he would uh,
yeah,
look up Jimmy.
He,
uh,
he would smoke weed.
There's picture of him smoking weed on
the Internet.
He's when he chances cigarette.
You sure?
I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
Because he did smoke weed alive.
He admits it.
And then,
you know,
I think that there were charges of Bush
used cocaine and then Obama said he did
a little bit of cocaine and shit like
that.
So what drives me fucking crazy is that
you have these guys who did all these
things.
They know damn well that what they did
at the time was just experimentation.
There's nothing morally wrong about it.
And now we have a system where we lock
up fucking thousands of people,
millions of people over the same shit.
Meanwhile,
they became president when they did
that.
You're running on that eight,
the eight years that he was in the
office.
How many people were locked up for
marijuana?
Exactly.
Yeah.
Not just,
not just for selling,
but for recreational use in certain
states.
There were people who got,
who have life sentences as a result of
nonviolent drug offenses.
Now to Obama's credit,
towards the end of his time in office,
he started doing a pardons and
commutations of those sentences.
But the thing that drives me crazy,
again,
to get back to one of my main points
here,
is I hate the fucking incrementalism and
gradual ism moving towards the thing
that we all know is the right answer.
We don't know the right answer is to
legalize it and fucking let every single
nonviolent drug offenders out of prison
and fucking apologized to him.
Not only that,
the hypocritical nature of having all
this coincide with the pharmaceutical
industry selling opioids that are
killing people at a radical rate while
they take contributions from us.
It's fucking crazy.
I mean,
they are literally a part of a drug
dealing enterprise.
I remember my,
my grandma on my dad's side,
I remember she passed away a while ago,
but I would go to her place and look at
her fucking medicine thing.
There were 70 different kinds of pills.
I was like,
holy
fuck.
She's getting zonked out of her mind on
a regular basis.
Like that's the whole point of it.
And I'm not even begrudging an older
person who's like,
fuck it,
I'm checking out unless you give me all
the pills you want.
But my point is,
if you're gonna,
if that's going to be the mentality for
them,
why,
why the fuck would you lock up poor
people for smoking weed or doing cocaine
or whatever the case is.
I don't think anybody could rationally
argue that.
I mean,
it's just seems at this stage of the
game,
especially when it comes to things that
are nontoxic or,
or,
or a nonfatal.
Things like marijuana or Kratom,
there's no argument against.
It doesn't make any sense.
Especially when you could go right down
the street.
You could go to the CVS and buy enough
liquor to kill yourself instantly.
Exactly.
Easily,
easily right here.
That,
that table right over there will kill
you.
Yeah.
If you drink all that for sure.
There's a table there with a big bottle
of gentleman's Jack.
There's a couple of bottles of whiskey
to some whiskey from some place in
Bakersfield and a big jug of wine dead
drink.
All that shit.
Dead.
One hundred percent.
So,
uh,
sorry to change topic so abruptly.
But I'm from New York.
The bagels here.
Fucking terrible.
Is that the water?
I don't know.
Must Be.
I was like,
this isn't a Bagel.
This is like a fucking piece of stale
bread.
Yeah,
I think it's the water.
I think it's the moisture in the air
too.
I wonder if the bagels are better in
Seattle.
Is it moisture up there?
Right?
It's wet and then I'm going to try the
pizza.
I'm going to try the pizza.
I think today,
here don't do it.
I'm going to do it just because I got.
I got to compare,
man.
I got to compare my whole life.
I heard like a New York piece is the
best.
Where do you live now?
And you live in the city and uh,
no.
I live just outside of the city.
I live in Westchester County still,
but not nourished.
Yell anymore.
It's better pizza for sure.
Did used to go to Nicki's pizza?
I went down the street from white
plains.
Been there once,
but there's one next to that called
[inaudible].
Have you ever been there?
I don't think so.
No.
Executive billiards.
If you walked out of executive and take
a right in white plains.
Nikki's was on the right hand side,
but I heard Nikki's burnt down.
Okay.
Nicky's had.
I only never had white pizza before
until I went to Nikki's and I had white
pizza.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
This is one of the greatest things
humans have ever created.
When you were there,
were there.
Was there the Strip of bars developed
yet on white plain in in white plains
or.
No,
it's hard to remember.
There was some bars there for sure,
but there were old dive bars and shit.
All we would do is go play pool.
Yeah.
Here it is.
Nikki's is still there.
Still there?
I think it's still a science.
What's that?
Stickers on the door.
Why is that shit on the door?
The right to the right of that?
It looks like there's like closed down.
Yeah.
Tim was there like two years ago,
so I mean it could have,
could have closed since then.
I think Mario's pizza in white plains.
Is it?
You have to trial.
It is open so it is open now.
So they must have did it burn down and
they rebuilt it because that was yellow
tape over the door.
Like police tape.
Oh yeah.
They cleaned it up fucking damn.
If they have the same recipe,
a run,
do not walk,
run to Nikki's and get some of that
white pizza or any of their pizza.
So speaking of your crazy stories about
at executive billiards and all the crazy
characters you've met there.
My friend Karen and I,
we,
when we were in high school,
we would go play poker at these
basically underground spots in new
Rochelle.
And they were either founders like the
movie with Matt Damon,
kind of,
but they weren't rushing.
They were either like weird,
weird fake mafioso dudes or real mafioso
do is we couldn't tell the difference.
We didn't know because they don't talk
like this and they're like hey Jimmy,
give me a fucking diet coke.
And all they would do is sit there and
smoke cigarettes the whole time.
And so we,
we played cards there and you know,
we had some friends who did well and me
and my friend probably lost money
overall,
but there was years later I was watching
a I turn on the TV,
just happened to be a local news report.
Learned that one of the guys who was
there,
God is fucking hand chopped off right in
front of the place.
And I was like,
well,
we were in over our heads now were we,
we were in high school,
one of the chop his head off for
stealing.
I'm sure it,
I'm sure they were real mafia mafia
guys.
And there was some shortcuts,
you know,
that's dark,
chopping a person's hand off his fucking
gave it to him here.
Go get this sewed back on bitch.
But what's funny is,
um,
they will fucking,
even though their mafia guys,
they were fucking like,
they were really nice to us with high
school kids and a lot of Mafia people
who are gentlemen.
The thing is like,
just can't be in the wrong situation.
You can't owe them money.
You can't be in a situation where they
can get money out of you or they can
extort money from you.
You know,
if you were running a business or
anything where they offered you
protection or any of that kind of shit,
like you're fucked man.
And that's why gambling should be
fucking illegal because it's illegal.
Push it underground.
Now those guys run it and then people
forget their fucking hands chopped off,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
In Vegas they just.
What are they doing to kick your ass?
Put you in jail.
Then the Vegas,
he used to run them off,
or the [inaudible] brothers.
I used to run funding everything.
Yeah.
Even a half a fucking Hollywood.
I'm sure it was financed with mobster
money.
Well,
you know,
we've talked about that many times at
Ciro's nightclub was owned by Bugsy
Siegel.
That's the comedy store.
There you go.
Yeah.
They used to be a total mob run joint
and to this day I've never,
I don't believe in ghosts,
but I'd go to the belly room.
I've gone to the belly room several
times with my friends,
like over the 20 years that I've been
there.
We go by when it's dark,
just stand there.
What do you think you feel?
Anything?
I'm fucking scared.
Heartbeat.
I don't believe in ghosts,
but I think energy is real and I don't
know whether we create in our own mind
where we look at something and we're
like,
I feel weird looking at cars.
Enter rooms give you a feel.
You walk into a room,
you get a feel off the roof.
Well,
people had been murdered there for sure.
And that's the thought process about
that place is that there's probably some
leftover weird vibes and I know a lot of
people that have seen weird shit there,
but I don't know if I believe them.
They say they've seen weird shifts.
I know Tony Hinchcliffe.
I saw the podcast where he was like,
I saw a ghost.
Maybe just so you know Tony,
I love you,
but I was at home going,
fuck off.
Fuck off Tony.
I've never seen a ghost there,
but I felt weird.
Like I said,
I've gone into the main room when it's
dark at night and I'll be gone by myself
and I shit
my pants,
I gotta get Outta here,
but I,
I definitely believe people were
murdered there and they used to be a
tunnel that would go from the back of
the comedy store all the way up to crest
hill,
which is a street above the comedy store
for the comedy store.
He used to own,
I think they bought the two of them
together and you.
It was like a tunnel where they take
booze and dead people and Shit and
fucking screwed him up there and throw
them in the back of a trunk.
I don't know.
It's a fun thing to talk about.
When you look at like all those tv shows
like haunted Hollywood.
The comedy store is very high on the
list.
Have you ever seen like the paranormal
fucking ghost hunters,
so stupid goofy shows ever?
It's like dark in a hallway and they
were running like,
shit,
I think I'm still over here.
That is the biggest cock tease of a
show.
I know.
Oh remember,
I'm John.
John Edward to guy crossing like it guy
and then he tried to do it with nine
slash 11 victims.
They were like,
fuck you.
Now you're canceled.
Yeah,
that's right.
You used to do it up until that time,
but I don't like how the fuck do network
executives approved shows where it's
like the fucking long island medium or
some shit and it's like they pretend to
talk to the dead.
How the fuck you going to put that on
daytime TV?
Like it's not complete and utter
horseshit?
Well,
that was one of the problems that
happened when I was doing that Saifai
show,
the Joe Rogan questions.
Everything showed.
They wanted to make sure that I wasn't
out to debunk a lot of the shows that
they would have
on their network and I can look.
I just want to find out what's going on.
I want to go.
Some of it's probably real.
I want it to be real.
Yeah.
That was an eyeopening experience.
Doing that show was very eyeopening
because I realized what kind of people
were really into these things.
They're just whimsical,
hopeful people that don't have much
going on and they want it to be real,
that there's a 10 foot tall,
furry man living in the forest or the
aliens come down,
suck people out of their beds and bring
them through walls in the middle of the
night and all that shit.
Well,
you really took it to the chem trail
people.
Yeah.
Those poor fox.
Well,
they did.
They despise you now get mad.
You're fucking chill.
Geoengineering is real brow.
What does Alex Jones say to you?
Because I know you're friends with him.
What does he say to you about chem
trails?
So you try to convince you?
No,
he thinks that most of what you see
according to him,
but to see Alex,
he goes with the weather a little bit
too.
He thinks most of what you see is just
condensation trails that happen when you
have a jet engine and you have the cold
air and condensation in the atmosphere
and the.
That's what they are.
I mean,
they're artificial clouds that are
created by a jet engine passing through
the air.
That's what they are.
You can do it over and over again.
You could do it right now.
The idea that they're spraying something
and that something happens to have
aluminum and Barium in it,
but it also looks exactly the cloud.
No,
that's moisture.
The reason why it looks like a cloud is
because it's a fucking cloud and one of
the things that I said in the chem trail
thing like go,
you want to talk about real chem trails?
Here's the real chem trail.
They're burning gasoline in the sky
above your head every day to turn to the
tune of thousands of flights.
You're not concentrating on that.
Instead,
you're concentrating on the natural
reaction of jet engines and moisture in
the air.
It's so stupid.
I don't get because there's a thing that
people do where it's almost like they're
trying to find the worst possible
fucking argument and then that's the
part of it that they get upset.
So that.
And this goes back to the thing about
trump where I told you on CNN all they
did for an hour and a fucking half was
talking about Russia and it's like I'm
sitting there going,
I just covered a story on my show last
week about how the head of the consumer
financial protection bureau is a guy
named Mick Mulvaney.
He took over $50,000 from the predatory
payday loan industry.
Donald trump at his inauguration took
over a million dollars from the
predatory payday loan industry.
They just scrapped the rules that we're
supposed to clean up that industry.
And now they're letting them charge 950
percent interest.
You want the fucking conspiracy?
There it is right there.
And you're not talking about Putin in
Russia.
He's a fucking Manchurian candidate and
loud noises and he curses a lot and
fucking stormy daniels.
I don't give a fuck about any of that.
Talk about the shit that matters.
I care about storming.
No,
I do wonder what's going to happen with
the indictments.
I do wonder.
So it was.
People were pleading guilty now and you
know,
the.
The concern is that it's going to
trickle.
So here's the thing.
Here's the thing,
is Donald Trump a corrupt businessman?
Fuck yes.
Anybody who says he's not has no fucking
idea what this has been into.
There's evidence.
He did deals with the Mafia.
He has a hotel in Panama which was
laundering drug money.
So do I think he's a criminal?
Yes.
Do I think he did money laundry?
Would it be good if somehow got him on
these things?
So of course it would be,
but the idea that he's a Manchurian
candidate or he did treason is so
ridiculous that it makes me a guy who's
massively anti-trump scarf and get
really angry when people try to push
that narrative,
and here's the thing there is it's an
open legal question as to whether or not
you can indict a sitting president.
Usually what has to happen is you have
to impeach a sitting president will.
Right now,
Congress is overwhelmingly Republican.
You know who's not going to fucking
impeach Donald Trump.
Even if they prove the worst case
scenario that he's some sort of
Manchurian candidate,
the Republicans are not going to fucking
impeach him.
So at the end of the day when the
Democrats focus on this ad Nauseum,
the reason they're doing that is because
it's something that they feel
comfortable and safe talking about
because they don't have to talk about
Medicare for all or free college or a
living wage or getting the corporate
money out of politics or ending the
fucking wars which they also support.
So they're not talking about real issues
and they're focusing on this,
the fake scandal and sensationalism
because they think will score them cheap
points with the electorate and it won't.
And they think there's an end game here
and there's not.
But there is something there,
right?
I mean if yes,
he made money,
but if people are getting indicted,
I'm sure with this Russia thing.
So I'll break that down.
Paul Manafort is one of the people who
got indicted,
super duper corrupt laundering money.
Michael Flynn,
saving money.
How so?
So in the case,
I know more of the details about flint.
So Flynn is a guy,
he got a,
he,
what's his face?
Molar went after Flynn and it was proven
that Flynn took $500,000 from the
Turkish government and in return for
that,
he pushed the trump administration to
not arm the Kurds who are fighting isis.
And the reason why is because Turkey
hates the Kurds and they don't want us
to arm the Kurds.
So in other words,
Michael Flynn was doing the bidding of
the Turkish government and pushing their
influence in our government and he
didn't register as a foreign agent in
the process.
So exactly.
So he's doing the bidding of the Turkish
government and not disclosing that.
And you have to register as a foreign
agent if you're going to take that money
and you're going to do that.
And this doesn't run down to trump.
Um,
well that's the open question as to
whether or not at some point along the
way,
whether it's with Russia or with other
countries.
By the way,
nobody talks about the fact that trump
registered eight new businesses in Saudi
Arabia when he was on the campaign
trail.
And then he just gave them over
$100,000,000,000 weapons deal.
He also took $270,000 from top Saudi
officials at his hotel when he was
president elect.
And then again he gave over
$100,000,000,000 weapons deal.
The case of Israel,
jared Kushner has a,
you know,
millions of dollars from Israeli banks.
And then Lo and behold,
when Donald Trump was president elect,
they tried to push the UN to not condemn
Israel over there,
illegal settlements.
So you have his entire administration.
It's just a grab bag of corruption in
foreign influence say.
But it's far influence across the board
and its influenced also from
corporations.
But again,
people are not focusing on the
corporations and they're not focusing on
the other countries that they're corrupt
with because there are hyperfocused on
the Russia thing and at the end of the
day they want to impeach trump over
Russia.
But like I said,
it's going to be hard to prove.
And then it's an open question.
If you can indict A.
I don't think you can indict a sitting
president.
You have to impeach.
They're not going to fucking impeach.
So really this is Democrats sniffing
their own farts and acting like they're
doing something important when they're
really not.
And the only they're there,
in my opinion,
is money laundering.
He's a corrupt businessman,
but he's not some sort of Putin puppet
because he's actually done many policies
that are against Putin.
So for example,
he armed Ukrainian rebels who are
fighting Russia right now.
You don't arm people who are fighting
Russia if you're there fucking puppet,
you know,
he,
he also is bombing Syria and we're
staying indefinitely in Syria.
They just announced that recently.
You don't that Syria,
the Syrian government,
that's one of Putin's top allies.
You're not going to permanently occupy
their country and try to fight that
government if you're in bed.
They're doing a NATO buildup on Russia's
border right now.
So if you're,
if you're a Putin's puppet,
you don't have a military buildup on his
border.
There was just a story the other day
about how now the US,
our military sending our ships,
uh,
to black seat,
right on Russia's fucking border.
So it's military escalation.
And that's another part of this that
pisses me off,
is that if the Democrats really want us
to resist trump,
resist that,
say,
I don't want to send our fucking
military to get into a standoff with
Russia.
I don't want to bomb Syria and
permanently occupy it.
This is how the Democrats should be
resisting.
They should be resisting trump from a
left wing position,
from an anti interventionist position.
But instead,
everything you hear from the Democrats
is pays under Putin spellman.
He needs to make sure that he's even
harder on Putin and he does more
sanctions against Putin and he escalates
further with Russia.
Listen,
man,
there are nuclear armed power.
Do you want to fucking get into a
confrontation with a nuclear armed
power?
We're sitting here living our lives just
going about our business.
And this is.
I mean,
this is crazy.
We're rolling the dice and we're playing
a game of chicken with Vladimir Putin.
Do you think that they're just caught up
in this sexy thing?
Yes.
A lot of it is sensationalism.
Also,
what the public is really focused on
right now,
so it's something that gathers ratings.
I think they're driving it.
I think it's driven from the top down,
from the establishment media down from
the Democrats down.
Because again,
if you talk to regular people,
they're fucking hurting,
right?
Wages have been stagnant since 1980.
There's 30 million people that don't
have healthcare in trump's first year in
office.
3 million more people last healthcare
because he did all these executive
orders that basically took a hatchet to
obamacare.
So you have all these people who are
really hurting their.
They care about their wages,
they care about,
you know,
not being saddled with over a trillion
dollars in student loan debt.
This is the shit regular people care
about.
So when they turn on CNN and they see
Russia,
even if you don't like trump,
I despise trump with every fiber of my
fucking being.
But when I see this,
I roll my fucking eyes and then they
have the nerve to say,
oh,
trump won't shut up about Russia.
You were talking about it all day and he
responded to it and because he responds
to it,
you're like,
oh,
there he goes again with Russia.
Yeah.
It's going to be interesting to see how
this all plays out.
I'm really fascinated.
I'm fascinated to see if he can make it
out of four years.
Well,
not only.
I think he's gonna do think he's going
to run.
He's going to run again and he's going
to win again.
He has a chance.
He has a fucking chance because the
Democrats,
if the Democrats run Kamala Harris,
if they run cory booker or any of the
other corporatists he can win because
he's going to go right back into his tap
dance about being a populist and helping
people and guess what?
In the first few years of his tax bill,
regular people did get a tax cut,
so he's going to say,
look,
you look at your tax bill.
I just gave you an extra thousand
dollars this year who you want to vote
for?
And so there is an argument that he's
going to make to the people and if you
don't have somebody like Bernie Sanders
or Bernie Sanders talking about the
issues that matter to people will then
of course he can fucking win again.
Listen,
there was.
I was laughed at when I said if it's
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton,
he can.
When people left at me because they
didn't want it.
Didn't want it to be true because.
Yeah.
Because then the narrative story,
all you saw was that there was like a 75
percent chance that hillary was gonna
win the fucking Huffington Post.
One was over 99 percent.
No God before the election to the
election.
So silly.
I know though,
and the way they calculate it,
such good articles to the sprinkler and
great articles.
That's easily horseshoe.
The trick is avoid the opinion section
and.
But if.
But if you stick to the actual
journalists and then they do a good job.
It's got to be embarrassing for them
all.
For the journalist.
Yeah.
They're like,
you guys are fucking shitting all over
the hard work that I do.
You know,
Kyle,
it's been a lot of fun,
man.
This has been a lot of fun,
I really appreciate it.
Let's do it again.
Oh,
anytime.
Thanks for your time.
Really appreciate it.
This was a lot of fun.
I enjoyed this.
Thanks.
Tell everybody where they can find a
show,
a youtube.com/secular talk,
and if you want to follow me on twitter,
it's at Kyle Kalinsky.
Boom.
That was great.
Mm.